[Auto-generated transcript. Edits may have been applied for clarity.]
כן. כן. אוקיי.
אז שלום לכולם. כזכור, שיעור הבא הוא שיעור חזרה אליי.
עדיין לא קיבלתי שאלות. אז בבקשה לשלוח.
בסדר. והיום נסיים את הדיון בפוסט טריינינג ואחרי זה נדבר על זה ומשם נראה עוד.
אם יהיה לנו קצת זמן אז נדבר על נושא נוסף.
טוב, אז התחלנו לדבר בפעם שעברה על המשחק models ועל Post training.
כן, ובעצם הבחנו בינם לבין מודלי השפה כפי שהכרנו אותם בעצם מתחילת הקורס ועד עכשיו.
אז אולי מישהי או מישהו זוכרים מהי האבחנה כאן? אוקיי, נתחיל ככה.
מה זה Language מודל כפי שאתם מכירים אותו? מה ההגדרה?
על התפלגות המשפטים? אוקיי, בדיוק. זאת אומרת זאת מידת הסתברות על פני משפטים או באופן כללי מחרוזות סופיות מעל איזשהו אלף בית נתון.
נכון, ודיברנו על כל מיני שיטות לעשות את זה כדי לנסות לשפר את היכולת.
האימון שלו בגדול מאמנים אותו כדי שהוא יוכל לתת הסתברות שהיא כמה שיותר נאמנה להתפלגות שממנה אנחנו מניחים ש הקורפוס נדגם.
כן או הקורסים נגיד אחלה. מה זה extract language model?
אוקיי, אז באיזשהו שלב עבר Shift היה Shift די משמעותי.
נכון, זאת אומרת, אני מניח שלא מעט מכם משתמש או השתמשתם בעבר ב language models.
נכון, כמו למשל דרך צ'אטבוט הזה החביב עליכם, אני לא יודע Gemini או צ'אט, GPT או Cloud או כל אחד מהדברים האחרים.
וודאי שמתם לב שעל פניו ההגדרה הזאת לא לגמרי מתיישבת.
ההגדרה, כפי שהגדרנו עכשיו של האימוג'י Model, לא לגמרי מתיישבת עם ארטיפקטים מאותו כן עם חבילת.
לא יודע אם מוצר התוכנה שאיתו שוחחתם או ניהלתם איתו אינטראקציה בכלל.
למה? בגלל שבעצם המוצרי התוכנה האלה המטרה שלהם היא אחרת?
כן, המטרה שלהם היא לא פשוט לעשות Density stimulation לאוסף של טקסטים כן או לאיזושהי התפלגות שממנה נפגמת.
שמן המדגמים טקסטים, אלא המטרה היא בעצם להיות סוג של conversation agent.
קוראים לזה לפעמים לא לגמרי ברור מה נופל תחת ההגדרה הזאת ומה לא,
אבל בוודאי שזה כולל יכולת מענה על כל מיני שאלות עובדתיות בצורה כמה שיותר נכונה ומדוייקת וכן ומפורטת ולעזור להתייעץ.
אני יודע איך מתקנים משהו בבית או איך מארגנים מסיבת יום הולדת או כן אין סוף דברים שאתם ודאי מכירים טוב ממני ששואלים אותם אוקיי, עכשיו מה ההבדל המהותי?
מה ההבדל המהותי? מדוע זה לא רק next post production?
אז כן, דוגמה שנתתי שאני חושב ניסיתי להדגים את זה.
מישהי או מישהו? זוכרים את השאלה את הדוגמא הזאת ומה ניסיתי להעביר דרכה?
כן, בארץ רוב האנשים חשבו שפעם אנשים חשבו שבארץ שטוח, אבל זה לא נכון עדיין, מרוב האנשים, מסתבר, חושבים שפעם אנשים חשבו שכדור הארץ.
בימי הביניים אנשים לא חשבו ככה, וזה ההבדל בין השלמת משפטים הגיונית.
אם האדם המתאים יענה לבין מה הנכון. מה התשובה הנכונה?
כן, בדיוק. אז בעצם קריטריון של מודלי שפה כפי שאתם מכירים אותם היום, הם לאיזשהו מובן של נכונות או התאמה לאיזשהו רפרנס פוינט כן, בין אם זה הידע המדעי,
ההתנהגות המוסרית כפי שהיא נשפטת על ידי מפתחי התוכנה באזור סן פרנסיסקו והמפרץ, שם לא משנה איזשהו Reference point שהוא מעבר לפשוט.
להיות מסוגלים לייצר משפטים שלפיה או לתת הסתברות גבוהה למשפטים שסביר שאנשים יגידו אותם ואפשר לקחת או יכתבו אותם במקרה הזה,
ואפשר לקחת את הדוגמא הזאת ולראות אותה. נגיד שהיינו רוצים להשלים מהרס תמידי וליופי Colors live the earth walls.
אז אם אנחנו לוקחים מודל מהסוג הלא Instruction, בואו נקרא לו המודל הקלאסי, כן או לא יודע איך נקרא לו בדיוק, כי לשניהם קוראים language model.
כן, זה חלק מהבלבול כאן, גם לסוג הזה וגם לסוג כזה. אז אנחנו מאוד נשמח שהוא יפלוט לנו דברים כמו flat למשל או flat.
דיסק או משהו כזה נכון? למה נשמח שהוא יפלוט את זה?
גם אם המחקר ההיסטורי מראה שזה לא נכון? תחזית ספרות?
כן, בדיוק בדיוק. זאת אומרת, זו השלמת משפט הגיונית.
אז למשל, תחשבו על זה כמשהו שאמור לתת איזשהו prior לספייס טו טקסט.
נכון, זה טוב אם הוא ייתן הסתברות גבוהה לפלט כי או הפלט דיסק או מה שזה לא יהיה, כי זה משהו שסביר שאנשים יגידו נכון,
וגם אם אתם עכשיו משתמשים במערכת Speech to טקסט כדי לעשות טרנזקציה של נאום של גבלס או משהו כזה,
כן, לא עלינו, אבל לפעמים בצרכים היסטוריים, אז אתם תרצו שהוא ייתן הסתברות גבוהה למילים.
גבלס אולי עשוי היה להגיד נכון, גם אם זה תכנים אנטישמיים.
כן, כי זאת לא. המטרה היא לא לקלוע לאיזושהי כן.
לא יודע מה לאיזושהי התנהגות מוסרית ערכית נכונה מדעית מתוקנת וואטאבר, אלא פשוט לנסות לשקף את ההתפלגות של הטקסטים.
לעומת זאת, מודלי Instrument היו הרבה יותר רוצים לתת משהו באמת כמו Almost 3 32GB in struct נותן.
Most divine scholars believe that the first was at the Center of the universe.
בלה בלה בלה בלה בלה בלה בלה. בסדר ואולי גם נכתבו על זה שפעם חשבו שזה הפלט, אבל היום זה לא.
וכל מיני דברים מהסוג הזה, כלומר הצורה שהמשימה מוגדרת היא שונה.
לא השתנתה רק הטכניקה. זה מאוד חשוב. המעבר בין הנוירולוג כהנמן מרקוביץ לנוירולוג אלם, לפחות כפי שהצגנו אותו עד עכשיו, לא שינה את המטרה.
בשניהם המטרה היתה אותה מטרה ואפשר היה לבדוק עם Language מודלים.
מרקוביץ גם כן עם מודלי סופר מרקוב ומבצעים את הפעולה טוב יותר ממדדי שפה רעננים או להפך.
כאן המטרה השתנתה. אוקיי, ובעצם כדי לעשות את זה, מטבע הדברים צריך לעשות משהו מעבר לפשוט, לנסות לתקן,
למזער את הפרק על דאטה או או משהו מהסוג הזה מעבר לנסות לבצע production בצורה טובה צריך באיזשהו מובן ספיציפי או עם פליסיטי להגדיר מהי ההתנהגות הרצויה.
כן, מהי ההתנהגות הרצויה, מהו אותו הדבר שלפיו היינו רוצים שהמודל יתנהג?
עכשיו כמובן שמכיוון שהמודלים האלה הם אמורים גם להסביר לנו איך לתכנן את יום ההולדת וגם להסביר לנו
איך לתכנן טיול וגם להסביר לנו כל מיני מושגים מורכבים בפיזיקה מודרנית וכן הלאה וכן הלאה וכן הלאה.
מאוד קשה בדיוק להגדיר מהו אותו רפרנס פוינט, אבל בכל זאת צריך לעשות משהו.
אז בוא אני אסביר לכם קצת על הגישה הסטנדרטית לעשות את זה כפי שאנחנו מכירים אותה בקהילה המדעית.
מטבע הדברים, הרבה מהדברים פה אני מניח שהגישה הכללית היא עדיין כזאת, אבל בוודאי הפרטים הם סודות מסחריים.
כל חברה מנהלת בדרך שמתאימה מתאימה לה.
אז בגדול. אוקיי, אז הבנו את ההבחנה בין Language Models קלאסיים או בין Pre training, כי למעשה Pre training זה פשוט לאמן מודל.
כמודל שפה קלאסי כן Cross Center Plus על פי דיקציה של המילה הבאה מה שלמדנו עד עכשיו.
אז שאלות לגבי זה על struct models? אוקיי, אז עכשיו מה בכל זאת עושים?
אז השלב הראשון זה מה שקוראים לו soft הרבה פעמים או provided fine tuning.
דיברנו על זה קצת ממש בסוף השיעור האחרון. בגדול, מה שאנחנו כבר כאן עושים זה מבחינה טכנית.
אנחנו עדיין משתמשים בקרוס אנטרופי לוס על Next, וורדפרס. כן, מבחינה טכנית לא השתנה כאן שום דבר.
ההבדל הוא בדאטה. עכשיו במקום לקחת Data באיזה לפי איזושהי התפלגות שאיכשהו עשינו קולינג ברחבי האינטרנט והוצאנו את זה.
כן. אז במקום לעשות את זה, אנחנו מגדירים מה הם המטרות שלנו, כן או מה יהיה ההתנהגות הרצויה.
ומנסים לכוון את המודל לכיוון הזה.
איך אנחנו עושים את זה? אנחנו מנסים לייצר training data בצורה לפעמים ידנית, לפעמים לא לגמרי ידנית.
ואז כן, אז אנחנו מנסים. זה הטלפון שלי.
כן. אה סליחה. אמממ. אוקיי.
אז בקיצור, אנחנו מייצרים Training data שאמור לשקף איזשהו סט של core skills.
קוראים לזה לפעמים כן איזשהם יכולות מיומנויות שהיינו רוצים שהמודל ישלוט בהם.
והנה נגיד דוגמה מאחד המודלים הפתוחים שעושים פוסט Training שהוא גם של אלן Institute for AI.
כן, אבל לא ממני. 2 3 שכאן זה היה knowledge whatever it is.
אני מניח שהכוונה היא לידע עובדתי על כל מיני דברים לגבי העולם.
ידע גיאוגרפי היסטורי בגדול כל מיני דברים שאפשר ללמוד מוויקיפדיה ככלל.
הרבה פעמים קוראים לזה knowledge למרות שזה מושג די עמום.
Reason כן. איך מסיקים מסקנות? צ'אט?
כלומר איך מנהלים שיחה, מה הכללים וכדומה. Coding math ו safety.
כן, אז זה עוד איזשהו קריטריון שאומר אני לא רוצה שהוא יפלוט תכנים רעילים גזעניים.
לא יודע מה שהם לא הגדירו שם בתור דברים שדווקא רוצים להקטין את ההסתברות שלהם, ואז אנחנו מאמנים את זה בדיוק באותה צורה.
כן next post production, רק שעכשיו על data שהוא rated כן שהוא נעצר כאילו עם א לא פשוט.
כל מיני דברים שדגמנו מהאינטרנט. בסדר, אז אז זה הסופר vibe fine Tuning.
כאן סיימנו בשיעור שעבר שאלות לגבי זה לפני שנמשיך?
אוקיי. אחלה. טוב. החלק השני בפוסט טריינינג.
קוראים לו בעצם הוא בדרך כלל.
כן, שוב אני אציג את הכל בצורה די סכמטית, אבל הוא בדרך כלל עוסק.
בעצם הוא עושה שימוש ב information כן בלמידת חיזוק שאני יודע שכל.
כמעט אף אחד. זאת אומרת, בודדים מכם מכירים את הנושא ואנחנו לא נדון בו לעומק.
אבל כן חשוב לי להסביר בערך את הרעיון שם, גם אם לא את הטכניקה אלגוריתמית.
אז. אוקיי, אז בגדול אפשר להגיד שיש לנו כל מיני.
נכון, יש כל מיני פרדיגמות שאנחנו מכירים בלמידה, יש את הלמידה המפוקחת.
נכון שבה אנחנו יש לנו את התשובה הנכונה ואנחנו בעצם יכולים.
כן, אם אנחנו חושבים על זה כתהליך כתהליך איטרטיבי,
אז אנחנו יכולים לחשוב על זה שיש את התשובה הנכונה ובאיזו צורה אנחנו יכולים לעדכן את הפרמטרים שלנו על סמך ההבדלים בין התשובה הנכונה לבין התשובה.
שחזתה. יש לנו one surprise learning. נכון שנגיד כמו class Steering יש self service learning.
כן שזה גם דיברנו עליו שזה מין משהו שהוא טכני supervision learning,
אבל מעשית זה מין משימה שהיא או גזילת או task כמשימה שאמורה ללמד אותנו לתת לנו בעצם ניחוש טוב או שם טוב לפרמטרים Brian Freeman learning.
בגדול, הסכמה נראית ככה. כן מעודד זה.
אנחנו בעצם חושבים על זה שיש לנו איזשהו סוכן כן או חושבים על זה שיש לנו בעצם איזשהו תהליך של קבלת החלטות.
אוקיי, זה שיש לנו מצב שבו אנחנו נמצאים, אוקיי, מצב של המערכת.
אוקיי, המצב של הסביבה. לא משנה איך זה שאותו אנחנו מגדלים.
אז בהינתן איזשהו מצב אנחנו צריכים להחליט איזה פעולה מבין אוסף של פעולות.
תכף אני אסביר איך הדברים האלה מתחברים למגדלי שפה.
כן, אבל באופן אבסטרקטי, מתוך המצב, על בסיס המצב שאנחנו נמצאים בו, אנחנו צריכים להחליט באיזה מאוסף של פעולות אפשריות אנחנו נוקטים.
אוקיי, אחרי שאנחנו נוקטים את הפעולה הזאת, המצב שלנו משתנה באיזשהו אופן.
כן, אז אנחנו בעצם. המצב שלנו משתנה באיזשהו אופן.
זה לא חייב להיות אופן שהוא דטרמיניסטי. בגלל זה כאן כותבים את ה Environment כי יכול להיות.
כן, תחשבו על זה שנגיד אני לא יודע מבצע פעולה של לנווט.
כן. אז יכול להיות שאני הולך בצד, מחליט ללכת קצת ימינה, אבל אז מתברר לי שהדרך חסומה, נכון?
אז כאילו לא הצלחתי לזוז ימינה, נשארתי במקום למרות שההחלטה שלי הייתה לזוז ימינה.
אוקיי, אז אז יש איזושהי אינטראקציה עם הסביבה, ובעצם האינטראקציה הזאת מעבירה אותי לאיזשהו מצב חדש,
והיא גם נותנת לי איזשהו Reward איזשהו Reward שלפעמים לא כל המצבים בהכרח נותנים Reward, לפעמים רק חלק, אבל נותנת לי איזשהו Reward בחיזוק.
כן, בעברית. בעקבות החיזוק הזה אני בשאיפה משנה את ההתנהגות שלי, משנה את האופן שבה אני מקבל החלטות לפי המצבים השונים.
אוקיי, אז זו צורה מאוד סכמטית והרעיון הוא שלמידה של למידה, של למידת חיזוק כן מפורסמת Learning מה שהיא עושה, מה שהיא אמורה לעשות זה למצוא דרך להתנהג.
זאת אומרת דרך להחליט על פעולות איזה פעולות אני רוצה לבצע, כך שאני ממקסם את ה Reward שלי בתוחלת.
אוקיי, כך שאני בעצם אני רוצה לחזק התנהגות שאני מקבל עליה Reward גבוה ולהכחיד או להחליש התנהגות שמקבל עליה Reward נמוך.
אוקיי, זה הרעיון הכי כללי ב פוסט מודרניזם.
זאת הפרדיגמה ככה ממעוף הציפור. בסדר. שאלות לגבי זה.
זה מוכר? פעם שמעתם את הסכמה הזאת שזה פעם ראשונה שאתם מכירים?
שמעתם? אוקיי, אחלה. אז זו הפרדיגמה. כן, State action Environment שמעביר אותה ממצב אחר ונותן לי איזשהו Reward,
ואז האימון הוא למעשה אופן שבו אני משנה את הדרך שאני בוחר Actions לפי המצב כדי למקסם בשאיפה את תוחלת הרובוט.
אוקיי, יפה. מה זה המצב ב.
מה כל מה כל הסיפור הזה קשור אלינו? כן, אני לא הולך במבוך ומנסה את זה.
אני מודל שפה. כן, עכשיו מודל שפה שצריך. מה לעשות?
מה עושה מודל שפה? כן עם Struct מודל? כן בדיוק הוא מייצר טוקנים זה מה שיש לו לעשות.
אין כאן איזה? כן, העולם סך הכל מאוד צר ומוגבל, אבל בכל זאת מתאימים את זה.
לכן לטרמינולוגיה הזאת, כדי להשתמש בכלים האלגוריתמים האלה, אז בעצם אנחנו חושבים על ה.
אנחנו בעצם חושבים על המודל. כן, על מודל השפה שלנו עכשיו הרבה פעמים קוראים לו פאי.
כן ולא. P. למה קערות פאי זה סימון די נפוץ ל Policy.
כן. האופן שבו אני בוחר את ההתנהגויות. אז עכשיו אנחנו חושבים פשוט על ההסתברות כי המילה הבאה פשוט בתור ה policy שלי.
זאת אומרת האקשן, האקשן. אז בואו נתרגם את זה עכשיו למושגים של force and learning.
ה state שלי זה מה שכבר יצרתי. הפרי fix.
נכון, זה המצב שבו אני נמצא. ה actions האפשריים הם מה כל ה.
כל אוצר המילים, כל וידאו, כל אוצר מילים. מי אמר ה?
כן, כל אוצר המילים נכון אלה האקשן. מה התוכן הבא שאני מייצר כולל Stop?
כמובן שאומר שאני פשוט עוצר ה environment כאן היא לא נורא מעניינת.
בגדול. אם אני בוחר לייצר Token, אין באופן עקרוני סיבה לחשוב שאני לא אצליח לייצר אותו.
כן, אז בדרך כלל אין כאן איזו סביבה מעניינת, אז אני פשוט מייצר אותו והריביות.
ומהו Reward שאני מקבל?
אז זאת שאלה נכון, אבל כאילו הרעיון בפרדיגמה הזאת זה שבאיזה שהיא צורה אני אשיג Reward סיגנלים שאומרים לי אם זה כיוון טוב ללכת בו,
כיוון רע ללכת בו ואז להשתמש באלגוריתם כאשר מפורסמת Learning.
שלא ניכנס אליה כאן כדי למצוא את ה policy האופטימלי וה policy האופטימלי.
זה פשוט מודל שפה אופטימלי. זאת אומרת Policy פה ומודל השפה זה פשוט אותו דבר, נכון.
כי אם האקשן זה Token וה state או fix אז מודל שפה זה פשוט סוכן שפועל בסביבה הזאת.
כן, מצאנו את זה. אז מצאנו במקרה הזה של חוסר מצב זה.
זה מה שכבר יצרתי ה X. כן, פיקס כן Reload למטה שהוא תכף נדבר עליו, אבל זה קומפוננטה היחידה שלא הגדרנו.
אבל באופן עקרוני זה משהו ש. ובשאיפה יידע להנחות אותי לעבר מחרוזות טובות יותר מאחרות.
כן, עכשיו אתם סובלים באופן סוג של חמדני. אז איך אתה יודע מה התגובה של סטיבן?
אוקיי, רגע שנייה. אז אוקיי, אז דבר ראשון זו שאלה טובה.
Force learning. בשונה מסופר Learning, אתה לא מקבל תסכול solution.
אוקיי, זה חשוב לומר כן, אתה לא Brian Force.
בדרך כלל אתה לא יודע כשאתה מתנהג כשאתה בוחר פעולות.
מהי אופן הפעולה הטוב ביותר? אתה רק יודע כמה טוב שזה מגולם באיזה שהוא מספר ממשי.
כן, כמה טוב סדרת הפעולות שכן בחרת לעשות.
אוקיי, בסדר. זה באמת הבדל חשוב Supervision.
אז מה שאנחנו מניחים? אז מאיפה מגיע ה Reward? אז מה שבדרך כלל מניחים כאן זה שיש איזה שהיא פונקציה.
כן, היא פונקציה שאנחנו לא יודעים. אין לנו באמת גישה אליה.
אפשר לקרוא לה proxy. כן וואי זה Continue.
כן, המשך של X איזשהו אקשן אפשרי או סדרה של אקשן עם אפשריים ו X זה זה.
זה פיקס, זה המצב הנוכחי ובגדול. אנחנו מניחים שהפונקציה הזאת שאין לנו גישה אליה אנו שמחים איתה.
לנו היא כזאת שנותנת. R נותנת תוצאה גבוהה יותר כאשר y הוא טוב יותר כי ההמשך ל x בסדר, אז זה בעצם ההנחה ואנחנו מנסים למקסם כן, כלומר למצוא, למקסם על מה?
אגב, מה המשתנה החופשי פה? כן, ה policy בדיוק למצוא את ה policy שם ממקסמת את תוחלת ה Reward.
כלומר שאם אני אדגים איזשהו פרי פיקס מתוך התפלגות הפרי פיקסלים שאני נתקל בהם, כן, שעליהם אני רוצה לאבדם ואבחר את יום Y או אבחר סדרת החלטות לפי Y.
שייתן לי continue. התוחלת של R כן תהיה הגבוהה ביותר.
בסדר. שאלות עד כאן. אוקיי, אז זה האופן בדרך כלל שמתאימים את זה.
אבל כמובן, אם היינו יודעים את R אז זה היה אחלה.
עקרונית אפשר להושיב אולי בן אדם שפשוט ישב באיזה חדר סגור.
נכון, כל פעם מקבל תוצאות. מודלי השפה נותנים לאיזושהי התחלה ויגיד זה שמונה, זה שבע, זה עשר, זה שתיים ולעשות אלגוריתמיקה.
כנראה שיהיה קשה לאייש את המשרה הזאת נכון? כי פשוט זה המון המון המון עבודה.
אז אנחנו רוצים לעשות את זה בצורה בכל זאת קצת יותר יעילה.
אוקיי, בעצם אנחנו רוצים לסמל חץ את R. במילים אחרות, מה שבדרך כלל עושים זה מסמלים את r.
שזאת הדרך. בדרך כלל כשעושים את זה כן. אז מה?
אוקיי, אז שוב, אם הייתה לנו גישה להר. כלומר, אם היה לנו איזה מתייג מיומן שיודע הכל והוא אשף בריסון ונוהג ב safety ותטא והיה נותן לנו את R על הכיפאק,
פשוט היינו מפעילים אלגוריתמיקה של important learning שתלמדו עליה בקורס אחר אם תרצו, אבל אין לנו את זה.
בוא נסכם לחץ. אז הנה הרעיון רעיון אחד לעשות את זה.
רעיון שהוא די, אני חושב, היה מאוד פופולרי כשהוא הוצע.
מאז כבר כמובן כל מיני. כל הדברים מתעדכנים בזה, אבל בגדול הוא די מייצג.
אז מה שאנחנו מניחים זה שיש לנו אוסף של פיקסלים.
אוקיי, שבמקרה שלנו זה Instructions. אוקיי, הוראות או משהו כזה?
כן. שיחה כאילו Turn. תור בשיחה אומר המשתמש אוקיי, ואולי גם היסטוריה של השיחה.
אם זה כבר הסתיים שיחה של כמה מהלכים, לא משנה איזשהו פרי פיקס שנתון כאן ועכשיו,
אנחנו מניחים שיש לנו איזשהו מודל שפה אוקיי, שיש לו איזושהי התפלגות נתונה P.
אוקיי, או פאי אתם יכולים לקרוא. האם אתם עושים לייק Policy? לא משנה.
כאמור, זה אותו דבר בהקשר שלנו, ואנחנו דוגמים ממנו ארבעה המשכים אפשריים.
אוקיי, פשוט דוגמים ממנו באיזושהי צורה. אולי grid, אולי זה bim Card שאולי San whatever.
אנחנו אנחנו באיזושהי צורה דוגמים, אבל מה שחשוב לצרכינו זה שכן.
אתם יודעים מה? בוא כדי להפוך את זה לפשוט, בואו נגיד שאנחנו ממש דוגמים ממנו.
זאת אומרת, כל Token נדגם ממש לפי ההסתברות שה language model מוציא.
בסדר, אז עכשיו מה אנחנו נעשה בעצם?
אנחנו נעשה את הדברים, אנחנו נעשה את הדבר הבא. אנחנו דבר ראשון נאמן מה שנקרא Reward mode.
כלומר אנחנו הולכים לאמן proxy לאותו ההר.
כן, איזשהו משהו שמקרב מסמלת את R והוא גם הולך להיות איזשהו מודל נוירוני.
בלי להיכנס לפרטים. כן, זה מה שמופיע פה בתור human model.
סליחה בתור וולדמורט. בסדר. איזשהו מודל נוירוני שמה הוא יודע לעשות?
לקחת x ו y ולתת מספר ממשי.
אוקיי, בסדר, אז אנחנו ניקח את הקונטקסט, את אותו פריט X.
ניקח את ה policy, כלומר את המודל, את מודל השפה שכרגע אנחנו מנסים לשפר.
כן, אנחנו נייצר ממנו ארבעה Continuous.
אנחנו ניתן ליומן Lable. אוקיי.
כלומר ניתן כאן אנחנו כן להעסיק בני אדם בחדר סגור שיצטרכו לומר איזה מתוך ארבעת האפשרויות היא הטובה ביותר.
שזה פשוט משהו שלרוב יותר מהימן. שואלים בן אדם.
אז תשדרג? כן, תשדרגו את הארבע האלה מאשר להגיד לו תן מספר 8 7 6.
זה מסתבר יותר מהימן. אז פשוט הוא צריך להגיד איזה מתוך הארבע הכי סבירה או או לסדר את כל הארבעה.
כן, זה כבר וריאנטים. אנחנו ניקח את ה reward model. אוקיי, ואנחנו נאמן אותו באיזושהי צורה.
בדרך כלל זה מין צורה אונליין כזאת. בגלל זה זה מתויג.
ככה נראה איך הרב וורדים של המודל שהוא נגיד רנדומלי נישליס בהתחלה ואז אנחנו מעדכנים, שונה מ הלייבל שהבן אדם נתן.
נגדיר איזשהו לוז ומעדכן את הפרמטרים. כן, אז איזשהו אונליין סופר בייס Learning סטנדרטי בשאיפה.
אחרי שעשינו את זה. אם עשינו את זה מספיק טוב וורד Model מספיק אקספרסיבי, קיבלנו משהו שאולי הוא לא.
כן. זאת אומרת, בהנחה שהיום אין לייבלים באיזושהי צורה, אם פוליציסטית מפעיל את R בעצמו ולפי זה הוא מחליט מה הוא הטוב ביותר.
אז הרי World Model הזה הוא לכל הפחות נמצא בקורלציה טובה בשאיפה עם ה R האינפלציוני שאותו היומן מפעיל.
אוקיי, זה לפחות התקווה, ואז מה שאפשר לעשות זה כפי שאתם מתארים לעצמכם, לקחת קונטקסט פשוט להפעיל rain force learning, כלומר לקחת וכל פעם לדגום קונטקסט,
להפעיל את ה policy, כלומר לדגום Continuous ממודל השפה, לייצר Reward model שהוא ייתן Reward שהוא לא ה Reward האמיתי r אלא Simulator.
אבל אוקיי, אולי בשאיפה עם בקורלציה מספיק גבוהה זה יתן לנו איזשהו Loss in Learning Lost וכך נעדכן את ה Policy.
עכשיו ביחס למעלה פירוט על הסוג בגדול פוסט מנט learning lost.
מה שהוא עושה זה הוא מנסה.
בעצם כן, יש לזה כל מיני וריאנטים, אבל הרעיון הבסיסי הוא שככל Reward יותר גבוה, ככה הוא יעדכן את הפרמטרים לחזק את ההתנהגות הזאת.
וככל שהרווח הוא יותר נמוך ככה הוא בעצם יחליש את הפרמטרים שמייצרים את ה Continuous הישן הזה.
עכשיו יש שם. זה עולם של כן, זה קורס שלם וגם הוא רק נוגע בקצה המזלג.
אז אני לא רוצה להיכנס פה ל אלגוריתמיקה, אבל הרעיון הוא שהתהליך הזה יש תהליכים מקובלים שעבור בדיוק בעיית האופטימיזציה שרשמנו כאן,
מיקסום תוחלת ה Reward על פני הפוליסה שלו.
עכשיו יהיה עוד דבר. יש כאן דבר אחד קטן שקצת השמטתי אבל הוא חשוב והוא מהו?
על מה בדיוק ניתן? הארי וורד או על לייבל?
כן. בדרך כלל. עקרונית היינו יכולים על הדגימה של ה Token לתת.
זאת אומרת לתת continue action. להגיד הנה יש לי עכשיו Token חדש שמגיע.
נכון? נגיד אני צריך לפתור את הבעיה. לא יודע נגיד.
מה נגיד הבעיה כאן? אוקיי, בואו נחזור.
הנה Most medieval scholars believe the walls.
אז אני הייתי יכול לתת לבן אדם כאילו להסתכל על ארבע אופציות למילה הבאה ולהגיד איזה יותר טובה.
אז נגיד האם יותר טוב flat אה at או זהו נגיד.
אבל זה קצת מצחיק. כן, כאילו כן, הוא יצטרך מין.
מה אני מצפה מהבן אדם שהוא ינחש את כל ההמשכים האפשריים שמתחילים בעט ולראות.
לא, זה לא רציני. מה יותר סביר לעשות? מה עוד קבוצה כוללת בדיוק?
תן לו לייצר נכון? ואז תן לו תשובה.
תשובה תשובה תשובה תחליט מה זה מ 4 הכי טוב נכון? עכשיו הדבר הזה הוא באמת הדבר שעושה הפרקטיקה המקובלת.
רק צריך לשים לב שהיא יוצרת פה משהו. בלי להיכנס לפרטים הטכניים קונספטואלית, היא יוצרת פה אתגר ואתגר למידה.
בגלל שבעצם ה Reward שאני מקבל הוא Reward שקורה בהמשך.
זאת אומרת המודל שפה צריך באיזושהי צורה ללמוד איך לייצר מילים, כך שבסוף התהליך הוא יקבל בתוחלת Reward גבוה.
אוקיי, אז כאילו אני מעביר את המשימה שחסכתי מהבן אדם נכון ולנסות להבין את זה כנראה לא טוב, כי אם הוא אמר עט הוא כנראה התכוון ל ככה וככה,
ולכן אני מעדיף לבחור את זה או משהו או אני מעביר אותה למכונה שאולי זה עדיף, אבל זו בעיה לא פשוטה.
כן, אם תחשבו על זה שוב, אינטואיטיבית הכל נגיד אתם עושים בעיות.
אתם מנסים לפתור בעיה של מוטוריקה? אוקיי, אתם.
אני רוצה להגיע להרים את הדבר הזה.
אוקיי, ואני צריך לבצע סדרה של פעולות עם השרירים שלי כדי להגיע לשם.
אוקיי, אני רובוט, אז עכשיו היה לי הכי קל אם פשוט הייתי יכול לעשות בזה.
נגיד אני מרים את הרגל. אז אתם תגידו לי Reward 3 אני מרים את היד תגידו לי Reward 4 אני מזיז את הראש תגידו לי Reward 1 וכן הלאה.
נכון, זה יותר קל מאשר אני עכשיו מבצע סדרה של 50 פעולות כן?
ובסוף תגידו לי 0 או בסוף תגידו לי אם הרמתי את זה נכון.
1. אוקיי, ואז אני צריך ללמוד מזה כי אני צריך ללמוד נכון איזה סדרות של פעולות שיש הרבה הרבה יותר אפשרויות.
ואז הייתי צריך להגיד אה אה, כנראה זה הזזתי את הראש.
30 פעולות אחורה היה רעיון די גרוע. כן, ואיך אני אבין את זה?
אני צריך די הרבה דוגמאות. כן לסדר את הראש ולהסיט את הפעולה, אז למה זה משנה?
לא? אז אולי במקרה הזה? אז אולי זה לא כל כך גרוע, אבל לא יודע. אולי אם הסתובבתי לכאן אז סתם בזבזתי, כי אולי גם יש לי Constant של זה.
לא משנה. כאילו מה שאני מתכוון לומר זה בוא נגיד אוקיי, בוא נשחק ככה.
בוא נגיד שעכשיו אתה לומד משחק שחמט. כן, באופן הבא אני לא מספר לך בכלל מה הכללים של שחמט, אפילו לא בחוקי.
מה חוקי או לא חוקי. אני רק אתה משרטט. אני מבצע פעולות, אתה מבצע פעולות ואני בסוף נגיד נותן לך אחד.
אם סדרת הפעולות שלך הייתה חוקית וגם ניצחת אותי ואחרת.
אפס. עכשיו בהצלחה. כאילו פה תלמד לנצח אותי.
כן, זה לא כל כך פשוט. כן אתה בהתחלה אתה צריך ללמוד מזה מה החוקים, אבל זה לא כל כך פשוט להבין מה החוקים, כי נכון כי.
לעומת זאת, אם הייתי אחרי כל צעד אומר לך זה צעד לא חוקי.
זה צעד חוקי אבל גרוע או זה צעד חוקי.
אבל טוב, כנראה היה לך אינטואיטיבית. שוב, זה כל הדברים האלה.
אפשר לפרמט אותם אינטואיטיבית זה הרבה יותר פשוט. אוקיי. בסדר.
יפה. אז מה התוצאות של התהליך הזה?
בגדול זה קצת שאלה. איך אתם עושים הערכה של הדבר הזה?
כן, ועל זה בדיוק דיברנו. מאוד קשה לעשות לזה אבולוציה. אין באמת סטנדרטים ברורים.
כאילו כן, יש שם הגדרות ברורות. למה זה אומר מודל שפה טוב יותר ממודל אחר.
דיברנו על זה קצת בשיעור שעבר. בדרך כלל משתמשים או באיזשהו אוסף גדול של בנצ'מרק, אם כן, או של צורות אבולוציה.
בשאיפה אמורות ביחד להוביל למסקנה שמודל א טוב יותר ממודל ב.
אבל זה כן. זה הרבה פעמים די בעיני המתבונן. לפעמים גם מה שעושים זה הרבה פעמים ה בנצ'מרק עם האלה.
מעבר לזה שקשה להגדיר את המשימה. יש הרבה מאוד בעיה של אובר פישינג.
כן, שוב יש המון עניין, המון עניין במודל עי שפה, המון חברות.
כן, גם אינטרסים מסחריים, המון מעבדות מחקר. כולן רוצות להיות הכי טובות.
מטבע הדברים עובדים עוד פעם ועוד פעם ועוד פעם על אותם בנצ'מרק פעם, ומה שמקבלים זה מודלים שמאוד מותאמים למקסם את אותם בנצ'מרק, בין אם מתכוונים לזה.
מה שהרבה פעמים מתכוונים או בין אם לא, זה לא לגמרי זה, אבל זה איכשהו מובלע.
כן. ואז אנחנו רואים כל מיני כותרות כמו Training for math does not transfer well to deep mind math, שזה benchmark שאמור למדוד את אותן יכולות.
כן, זה איזשהו ציטוט או models generally over feet.
Two if evil instruction following evaluation benchmark if evil instruction following performance very across categories.
בקיצור זה סיפור. אין לו באמת פתרון היום וזה אחת השאלות הפתוחות המעניינות.
שאלות עד כאן. הפרדיגמה הזאת של format learning עבור אימון מודלי שפה היא פחות או יותר ברורה.
לא, לא, לא ברורה. אוקיי, אני אקח את זה, כן.
וודאי שמעתם שבשנים האחרונות מה זה שם?
מקום טבעי? שנה אחרונה? לא יודע בדיוק.
משהו כזה כבר פחות ופחות קוראים לדברים כמו צ'אט, GPT או קלוד או לא יודע Gemini מודלי שפה ויותר ויותר קוראים להם Agents.
נכון? Conversations. Agents coding agents. Whatever.
כן. מה הכוונה? מה זה בכלל Agents?
ומה הקשר בין Agents לבין מודל שפה? אז גם זה התחום של מה?
מה? מה הם Agents? זה גם נושא סבוך בעל היסטוריה ארוכה.
אתם אולי מכירים את זה. מי שמכם? לקח קורסים? לא יודע אם מזכירים את זה בהקשר של קורסים של אלגוריתמי Game Fairy.
אם יש כאן כאלה מכם שאו שאף אחד פה לא לקח. נתקלתם במושג הזה בהקשרים אחרים?
Agent סוכן מערכות מרובות סוכנים מולטי agent Systems.
אוקיי, Anyway זה מושג עם הרבה מאוד באג במדעי המחשב שלא ניכנס אליו כאן.
יש עליו יותר דיון בקורס ב Advanced NLP, אבל הרעיון בגדול זה ש agent זה משהו שמסוגל לבצע פעולות.
אוקיי, להבדיל ממודל שפה שלפחות זו לא הגדרה פורמלית.
כאמור, כל נושא כל התחום הזה, הטרמינולוגיה שלו היא מאוד Washi Washi כזאת.
אבל בגדול הרעיון הוא שמודל שפה יודע לייצר טקסט כן, באיזושהי דרך, לפי איזשהם קריטריונים,
אבל בגדול מה שהוא יודע לעשות זה לייצר טקסט, בעוד ש agent הוא דבר שיודע לבצע פעולות.
כן, מהן הפעולות האלה? טוב, אם הפעולות הן פשוט פעולות ייצור טקסט, אז טוב, אולי הוא agent, אבל הוא בעצם גם מודל שפה.
זה לא נורא מעניין. אז זה נהיה מעניין אם נותנים בעצם למודל השפה גם לבצע בעצם דברים שהם מעבר לבצע Actions שמעבר לייצור טקסט מעבר לייצור של התוכן הבא.
למשל, אם מאפשרים לו לשלוח HTTP לכל מיני web Apis שונים ומשונים.
או כן לא יודע כדי לקבל את תחזית מזג האוויר או כדי לבצע חיפוש בגוגל או כדי לקרוא את תיבת האימייל שלכם,
או כן כל דבר אחר שאפשר לבצע על ידי כן על ידי Rest כזה.
או שלפעמים ל agents נותנים לכתוב קוד ולהריץ אותו כל עוד זה רק לכתוב קוד.
כשאין שום כן, אין שום גישה לאינטרנט או ל Compiler או משהו כזה.
אז אפשר עדיין להגיד שזה פשוט רק קיצור טקסט. אולי אחרי זה מישהו הולך ומקפל או מריץ Enterprise על הטקסט, אבל זה כבר לא מענייננו.
אבל ברור שמרגע שגם נותנים למודל השפה לבצע את זה, זה משנה כבר את היכולות והפוטנציאל.
יש כאן אפשרות להגיע ל פרפורמנס הרבה יותר מתקדם.
כן, אפשר גם לאפשר לו לעשות כן בעצם להשתמש ב browser.
כן, באיזושהי צורה מוגבלת יותר או פחות וכל הדברים האחרים שאתם.
מי מכם שמשתמש בכן בדברים כאילו שהם שיש להם גישה כמו קודקס כמו נכון כמו קלוד קוד.
אם נותנים לו חלק מן ההרשאות שהוא מבקש ולא אומרים לו כל הזמן דונטלו כן.
אתם מכירים את זה ודאי טוב כמוני. הנקודה החשובה היא.
בעצם הטכנולוגיה של ה Agents. בגדול, היא מסתמכת בדיוק על אותם מודלים כמו מודלי האבסטרקט שדיברנו עליהם, כשההבדל הוא שעכשיו,
בעצם במקום של מודלי השפה, ייצרו, נגיד ייצרו טקסט שאולי הטקסט הזה הוא במקרה HTTP פריק או Sto במקרה קוד, או במקרה זה.
ברגע שיש להם גישה גם כן לכלים הנוספים, גישה למערכת הקבצים שלנו, גישה ל web גישה לכל הדברים האלה.
אז בעצם א. הם יכולים לקבל פידבק בצורה הרבה יותר מהימנה משהם קיבלו קודם.
זה כבר לא בן אדם שיושב ואומר אני מעדיף את אחד על 2 או 3 על 4.
יש קומפיילר שאולי כל הזמן הם יכולים להתייעץ איתו נכון ולראות אם זורקים Compilation error לראות אם ההרצה לא רק קומפיילר,
אולי גם כן איזשהו execution engine לראות אם ההרצה מובילה לתשובה שציפינו לה.
לא שציפינו לה כן ולהתעדכן בעצם בהמשך.
אז אני כבר לא צריך את הבן אדם, את הלבלר שיבוא ויגיד לי א טוב יותר מב.
אני באמת יכול לבצע אינטראקציה עם הסביבה ולנסות לראות אם בסופו של דבר התוצאה של הפעולות האלה מובילות אותי לתוצאות רצויות או לא רצויות,
ולפי זה להגדיר איזשהו סוג של Reward. עכשיו כמובן Easier said דנדן ויש על זה גם קורס.
גם דגש בקורס ב Advanced NLP וגם טום הופ מעביר קורס מתקדם בנושא שספציפית מתמקד בסוכנים.
זה פשוט כדי שתכירו איך כל המושג הזה מתחבר אז, אז זה באיזשהו מובן המשך ישיר של הנושא של struct Models.
רק שעכשיו האקשן Space הוא הרבה יותר מתוחכם וה Reward והאפשרויות שאנחנו יכולים לקבל איתן Reward גם הם בהתאמה הרבה יותר מתוחכמות ואוטומטיות,
מאפשר לנו לבנות עוד הרבה טכנולוגיה על גבי זה. אז כן, בגדול זה מסכם כאן את התקן.
את הנקודה הזאת עם struct models בעצם שינו את ההגדרה של מה זה מודל שפה.
הרעיון הוא לעקוב אחרי הוראות. לאחרונה גם לבצע פעולות וזה תחום שנע מאוד מהר.
מאוד קשה להגדיר מטריצות Value הטיות ברורות לגבי מה טוב יותר מהאחר, כמה אנחנו יותר טובים מאיפה שהיינו שנה שעברה.
וכל הדברים האלה בדיוק מתחברים למשבר האבולוציה ולקושי באבולוציה שדיברנו עליו בשיעור הקודם.
בסדר, אז אחרי ההפסקה אנחנו נעבור לדון בתוכנית סדציה.
איזה שהוא תת תחום חשוב שקצת רצנו עליו במהלך הקורס, אז נחזור עד אותו.
רגע. למה אני מתכוון לאחרים?
תשובה. זו. הסיבה שאנחנו סקרנים לדעת איך עושים את זה.
זה? זמן טוב.
כן. כן.
הוא אמור להגיד איזה מבין ארבעת ההמשכים שאת גרמת באותו מקום?
או אולי לדרג את כל האווירה? זה טוב כי הוא משמש כדי להבין את הדירוג.
בשלב זה בדיוק אתה מאמן את הריבוע מודל ואחרי זה אתה הולך ואתה.
הנקודה היא שללמוד. ההנחה המובלעת היא שלימוד לימוד מודל חומרי לימוד, מודל שיודע להבחין בין אנשים טובים יותר וטובים פחות.
זאת משימה משמעותית יותר קלה מאשר המשימה של לימוד לייצר טקסט למאמין.
אחרי זה ישנם טקסטים של לימוד. זאת אומרת שאם המודל לימוד לא מספיק טוב, אני מבטל את הטקסט שלי, גם אם זה נכון.
זה בדיוק בגלל שבדיוק בגלל זה הכניסו את כל העניין של זה.
רמזתי לזה בשקף האחרון והכניסו את כל העניין של האקשן ששם אתה אולי יכול לקבל גם וורד ממקור חיצוני.
נגיד אם יש. אם אתה עכשיו כותב קוד אתה יכול לבדוק מה זה פרוקסי קינטי ולראות מה אתה מקבל.
אם אתה מבצע תרגילים במתמטיקה אז אתה יכול להפעיל אצלו ידע וולפרם אלפא או מה שאתה לא מוצא כן,
הוא יפתור את זה לגמרי סימבולית ואתה יכול לתקן או להשוות את התוצאה אליה.
אישית זה עדיין לא מייתר את הזכוכית.
עדיין יש את הזווית השביעית. אתה לא יודע מה קורה שם של החברות, זה ברור.
מה שברור זה שהם משיגים המון רעיונות, פידבקים, קסמים, אינספור אנשים שנתנו להם בסוף פידבק או רייטינג או מה שזה לא יהיה.
זה סעיף הוצאה מאוד משמעותי. זאת אומרת They did not really cut out the human, אבל כמובן הם מנסים ככל האפשר.
אני משערת שלא תמיד יש מושלם.
נכון? אז עדיף להמנע מזה לאמן את המותג ועוד לא את המותג שלך, נכון?
אחרי זה מאמין אתה רואה שכן נראה על פניו. כן, שוב הם לא עשו פוליש לפני כן, אבל זה נראה כמו נחמד, קצת כמו דרך מתבקשת.
אז איך זה יכול להיות בכל זמן נתון? כן, צריך לעשות את זה.
לא, זה לא יכול. היה צריך לקרות. היה חסר לי משהו בשביל מישהו שלא צריך מפתח.
צריך ליצור קשר? לא בטוח.
יש לי זמן כרגע. בסך הכל הצטרפתי לקבוצה הזו של הצפנה על הרשת הפנימית.
אז אתה לוקח את המפתח בסמארטפון שלך? כמה שיותר מהר.
ככל שאנחנו יודעים יותר טוב. ואז הבנתי שלא אני צריך להזמין אתכם.
אז אתה מגיע עכשיו עם כפות הרגלים נכונים ושלא צריך להציל אנשים אחרים.
אתה יכול לעשות את מה היה כל כך הרבה שלג?
לא כל אחד יכול לגייס אותך. לא, זה לא מפריע לאף אחד ואתה אומר שזה נותן?
את לא יכולה להצליח בתוך הסיפור שלך.
ייתכן שהוא לא יאפשר לכם לראות את מה שהם עושים.
מה? יש לך כדי לעצור את הדבר הזה?
כי זה לא דבר של דפוסי התנהגות, בעיקר כשיש ילדים.
אין כל אחד צריך לדעת שזה בסדר. אבל אני אראה לכם איך לעשות.
את זה. אין דבר כזה. אני לא מבינה איך זה הופך להיות תכלס.
כי ברגע שיש לך בראש שלך זה מה שבעצם את הרושם הראשוני של הסלטיקס מושלמים, כמו גם אני רוצה יותר.
אלוהים סולח. זה לא היה ממש קשה.
מייקל סקופילד, שחקן השנה שעברה. יש כמה שנאה עצמית, אבל שניהם נמצאים בז'אנר זה.
אז למה אתה משתמש ב. מישהו יודע את זה?
הצג את הפרופיל? המלא שלי.
אז אני יודע שאתם בידיים.
טובות, אבל יש גם קצת הגדרות.
מתחכמות בעיקר של הקבוצה.
וגם זה כבר עכשיו הכל בסדר.
אבל מה שעושה לנו מה אתה רואה את העמוד הראשון?
זה לא כיף כי אתה יושב בכל מקום וזה נהדר.
שהייה של 2 לילות ברגע שיהיה לך חוויה של פעם.
בחיים שלי. מסכי המחשב.
אני חושב שאנחנו כותבים בצורה שונה את השם שלך.
אתה מנסה לגרום לנזק, אבל אתה עושה יום אחד יותר נכון את החלק הראשון, אבל אתה לא מצליח.
אתה לא מצליח לעשות את זה. מה אתה אומר על 2 ב 2?
אני מקווה שאתם מבינים נכון. איך אתה חושב שזה עושה טוב אם זה חשוב?
איך הפכת את המציאות לא תמיד טוב, ובכל זאת לא מצאתי את בית הכנסת והילדים.
ואז התברר לי משהו שמאוד רציתי לדעת שזה הכיוון של המחתרת היהודית.
אני לא מסוגל לשבת לידה לפני. כן.
מה זה השטויות האלה? האם זה בגלל שהוא סכנת נפשות?
יום אחד הוא כותב סיפור. זה עדיין לא נפתח באמת, אבל אני שואל אותו.
אני לא מבין כלום. עברתי בשלום, עברתי מתחת לשם.
בפירוש לא סיפור קבוצתי במועד ב ולא נתקלתי.
אדם לא חי, לא. טוב.
כן כן קראתי. או שאני חולה? מה זה?
השטויות האלה? סטודנט באוניברסיטה? כן כן, אני רוצה.
להצליח בחיים שלי. אני לא זוכר. דווקא לא קיבלתי תשובה על תהליך בהיסטוריה, אבל אני לא רואה בעיה.
אבל מה זה משנה? הוא אמר לי עכשיו זה בסדר.
אני לא יודע איך יהיה לי משהו להטמיע את זה ואז לשקוע בתהיות מנהיגות.
אני שם איזה משהו, ואז אתה לא צריך להצביע על זה כזה.
אפשר לשאול באיזה תיק כזה היה שר בממשלה?
מה שכן, לא הייתי מבוססת על מה שחשבתי. היה איזה משהו שאתה צריך לעשות את זה מסיבות עיתונאים, ולהשתמש לשם בעצמי בדברים של הרכב.
אוקי, אז אמרתי לך להיזהר וכל מה שצריך זה שיש שאלות זה לא טבעי.
יש מצב? טוב יותר?
זה לא חשוב. מה עוד אתה מדבר?
תקשיב, אני מציע לך פשוט לגשת לכל זה.
איך זה קשור לזה של שקעים? תמיד חשבתי שאתה מדבר שטויות.
אז אתה לא רוצה לראות את זה?
אני רק לשאול אותך מה ששמעת. אתה בטח רוצה לדעת משהו לא טוב.
אני ככה פשוט בסדר. 3 בסדר.
איך זה? מסתדר?
אז יש לי חריגה מזה. אני גם לא פיזרתי.
יש הרבה חריגה בסך הכל. חוץ מזה משהו לא שהופך את הבדיקה לדרוש בן זוגך לספר.
זה נשמע לך תשובה הגיונית? מה עוד אפשר לעשות כל שביכולתו?
על מנת לסמן את האושר הפנימי של ביתר שאת רוצה לשתף?
הבנתי שיש כאן משהו שהיה יכול להיות שותפים ברמה טובה יותר בספר הזה.
תסתכל על זה. אני מודע לכך שבעלי חיים.
כפי שהוא עושה את. זה?
אתה יודע שזה לא המצב? אני מוסיקה טובה.
קצב הלב של הבוקר עדיף על החופש הזה. מהבית.
צפייה בסרטים ואז תבין את זה. ממש מתגעגעים!
זה מה שקרה. לא כן? אני לא זוכר איך היא מרגישה בלעדיו.
שותים מים כדי להוריד אותו. גם. אני לא סיימתי, אבל אני חושב שזה שווה את זה בעצמך.
אתה צריך להשקיע את הזמן שלך. אתה רוצה לשמוע על איך אתה צריך לעבוד כדי לעשות את.
מה שיש לך? זה לא שאני לא יכול להמשיך ככה.
עכשיו תגיד לי אתה? לא יודע.
להסביר. לי מה? לא ברור לי מה לא בסדר.
שש שנים? שלום. כן, בדיוק זה קרה.
זה לא נראה לי נורא, אבל זה מה יש.
בסדר. אז אתה יודע שאתה?
רוצה לשרת? את הממסד?
אבל אתה לא. צריך את זה.
אתה? לא מבין את זה.
זה בסדר? עבודה קשה למשל של השנה שעברה.
לא ידעתי, אבל הייתי בטוחה שכל מילה.
נוספת. מיותרת.
לא יודעת מה הסיבה האמיתית. לא יודע איך אפשר להסתדר.
עם נשים בלי להזכיר את הכוח שיש בכל דבר.
פשוט לא הבנתי את הסיפור. לא ידעתי שאני עושה מופע.
זה המקום. זה? התחיל בקטן.
לא יודע אם זה בגלל שימוש.
בקונדום. זה נכון, אבל חשבתי שזה לא נעים בתוך הבית שבו.
יש. מרכז חדש?
אה כן. אה.
מצד שני. ואני לא יודע איך.
להתמודד עם זה. זה? אני?
לא. חושב?
שהילדים? שלי.
בסדר. תודה רבה. כן, זה מה שרציתי להגיד.
מעולה! לא צריך יותר מזה.
כן כן זה הדבר הכי טוב. כן כן, זה אומר.
שתמיד צריך לדבר. עם אני מנסה לנסח את זה, לסדר את זה.
ברור שאנחנו לא עושים את זה, אז זה ממש.
לא? בסדר.
עכשיו אני רוצה לדעת מה היה שם.
מה לא בסדר? כן כן.
כן. כן.
טוב. נמשיך. אז אני רוצה לדבר על נושא שהזכרנו לאורך הקורס בכמה נקודות, ואני חושב לא דנו בו אף פעם בצורה ממש מסודרת.
ולכן גם מסיבות אלה וגם בגלל בקשה שקיבלתי מאחת התלמידות, החלטתי להקדיש לו שיעור בנושא הזה.
נושא טוקינג מיה, שהוא נושא מאוד קריטי בעיניי ועל כן והרעיון הבסיסי.
אתם כמובן כבר מכירים. אנחנו רוצים לקחת טקסט ולחלק אותו לתוכן.
כן, סליחה, להפוך אותו לשרשרת של Token שעליה נוכל לעשות את העיבודים כפי שראינו.
אם זה לא אם זה יהיה Transformer מודל מרכיבי ארנק או כל דבר אחר.
תוכנית סדציה. למרות שזה לפעמים נראה כמו מין שלב, כן, פשוט איזשהו שלב מקדים.
אוקיי, צריך לעשות משהו עם הטקסט כדי להכניס אותו, אבל זה לא ממש משנה.
מסתבר שזה לא המצב. פוליטיזציה מאוד משנה והושקעו הרבה מאמצים בשנים האחרונות כדי להתעסק בתוכנית סדציה,
לשפר אותה בכל מיני דרכים לייעל אותה, ואנחנו קצת נסביר את בעצם מה עומד מאחורי זה.
אז כמובן שהשיטה הפשוטה ביותר גם דיברנו על זה קצת בפרק על דקדוק.
השיטה הפשוטה ביותר שאפשר להתחיל ממנה זה פשוט לחלק לפי רווחים.
כן, לפי White space רווחים ליין פיד כל הדברים האלה.
כמובן שאי אפשר בדיוק להשתמש בגישה הזאת, כי צריך כן לקחת בחשבון סימני פיסוק.
נכון, נקודות הן מופיעות בלי רווח, פסיקים מופיעים בלי רווח, סימן שאלה, סימן קריאה.
הסימן שאלה הפוך הזה שנמצא בתחילת המשפט בספרדית ואולי בעוד שפות.
כן, כל מיני דברים כאלה צריך איכשהו לטפל בהם על ידי חוקים.
אבל אוקיי, זה איזשהו close class. בשאיפה גיבור טייק.
אפשר לכתוב כל מיני Regular Expressions שיטפלו בהם, אבל אפילו שם כשאנחנו מתחילים קצת לחשוב על זה יותר לעומק,
אנחנו רואים שזה שאפילו בגישה הפשוטה הזאת יש מקרים שלא כל כך קל להגיד אם צריך להיות רווח או לא צריך להיות רווח.
זה יחידה נפרדת, זו יחידה לא נפרדת. מה הקריטריונים שעל פיהם אנחנו מחליטים אם היא נפרדת או לא?
נכון, וחלק מהדברים האלה אנחנו כבר ראיתם, נגיד עם Missing עם סימן קריאה.
כן, אולי אפשר להגיד שהמיזוג עם סימן קריאה זה משהו אחר, ממש כמו אתם יודעים Raising Partners או משהו כזה.
כן, זה מין משהו קפוא כזה לכשעצמו. כן?
או state of the art. כן, שזה מין ביטוי קפוא, כזה שהרבה פעמים כתוב עם מקפים או Anything cable.
כן, שלפעמים כותבים את זה ככה כדי להדגיש את ה on.
כן או וכן הלאה. מה לגבי מקרים של קליטה?
נכון, גם עליהם קצת דיברנו כמו Aren't או כן או Isn't או לא יודע מה haven't מהפוסט טרופי S וכן הלאה.
מה לגבי שמות שמכילים הפוסט אופי?
אולי זה דווקא הכיוון ההפוך, נכון, כמו נגיד השם האירי המקובל אוניל כן או אוהרה, או כל מיני דברים כאלה שנהוג לכתוב אותו באנגלית עם הפוסט רוף.
אבל אולי זה לא נשמע כל כך הגיוני שם דווקא להפריד. זאת אומרת, כנראה שבמקור הגלי של שם משפחה הזה.
כן, היה אולי מקום להפריד, אבל ברור שכיום זה פשוט שם.
אז אפילו בגישה הפשטנית הזאת כבר אנחנו נתקלים בבעיות.
ואולי הבעיה הכי חמורה שאנחנו נאלצים להתמודד איתה בעצם בגישות פשטניות.
לוקליזציה זה מה אנחנו עושים כשאנחנו נתקלים במילה cannon word, מה שנקרא נכון מילה שלא נצפתה בטיימינג time מופיעה לנו בטסטים.
מה עושים איתה? דיברנו קצת על זה, נכון?
שוב חלק מהדברים כאן הן נקודות שאני מחבר את הנקודות בין דברים שכבר דיברנו עליהם וחלק זה יהיו נושאים חדשים.
אז דיברנו על זה שאפשר להוסיף Anyone Word Token נכון?
או שאפילו במקרים מסוימים אפשר להשתמש בסודה Words? מישהו מישהי זוכרים מה זה so the words?
נשמע מוכר? אנחנו צריכים בערך.
מתי דיברנו על זה? באיזה הקשר דיברת? דיבר עם כאבים?
חשוב לזכור במה כרוכים. אוקיי, נכון, כי מה עשינו שם וזה משהו מאוד עצוב שזה עדיין לא הסתיים.
במילים אחרות כן. אוקיי, הסתברויות?
אז איך בדיוק טכנית? מה עשינו שם ואיך בדיוק הגדרנו מחלקות?
הגדרנו מחלקות של דברים שאנחנו, שהם נדירים ואבל שאנחנו מצפים שתהיה להם התנהגות דומה.
נכון, כמו ארבע ספרות שאולי זה פשוט מציין שנה.
כן, לפחות באיזשהו טווח מסוים או דברים שמופיע בהם נקודה.
כאילו כמו יונק. כן.
דברים כאלה שאנחנו מצפים שזה יהיה ראשי תיבות הקרנים וכן הלאה.
אבל זה פתרון שהוא א זורק די הרבה מידע.
נכון, כי USA זה אותו דבר כמו כל דבר אחר שכתוב עם נקודות באמצע.
נכון, זה פשוט. שניהם אירופים בדיוק אותו דבר. בעוד שכנראה יש לנו הרבה דברים ספציפיים להגיד על USA.
אוקיי, אולי USA הוא יהיה יחסית נפוץ, אז הוא לא יהפוך ל so the world.
אבל, אבל הרעיון ברור, וגם בהרבה מקרים אין לנו את הרמז.
האוטו גרפי הזה כן, דרך דרך ה non non אלפא נומרי Characters או כל מיני דברים כאלה.
אז מה עושים שם? מעבר לזה, אפילו אם אנחנו מסתכלים על non words,
נראה שאנחנו הרבה פעמים דנים את עצמנו לספר City שאולי הוא לא הכרח המציאות כן לדליפות נתונים שאולי הוא לא הכרח המציאות.
כי בעצם אם אנחנו מגדירים World for Token, אז כן, כלומר מילים שלמות שמוגדרות נגיד בין White Space ו White Space פחות או יותר.
אז אנחנו לא קושרים יחד את הפרמטרים של Open opening open וכן הלאה או אכלתי,
אכלנו או אוכל, נאכל, יאכלו אולי אפילו עם אוכל וכאלו ושמות עצם שכן אכילה ודברים כאלה כן.
אז עקרונית היינו רוצים להיעזר בזה שיש כאן בעצם משותף בין המילים.
מצד שני של מילים נפרדות. אז מה כן?
אז מה אפשר לעשות? דרך אחת זה מה שנקרא Circular לפלטות Sensation.
אוקיי, סך הכל הרעיון כאן הוא די פשוט. כן, Split בעיקר Actors.
אז למשל את המשפט Split בעיקר Actors אנחנו נהפוך לסדרת התרגילים שכתובה כאן.
בסדר. עכשיו בואו נסתכל על הדבר הזה.
מצד אחד יש לו יתרונות ברורים אוצר המילים שלנו יהיה מאוד קטן, נכון?
כלומר עם Padding layer. שתזכרו שזה בדרך כלל המון פרמטרים.
נכון זה זה המימד של החישוב הפנימי כפול גודל אוצר המילים.
כן, יש לנו שם איזה מטריצה ענקית שאנחנו צריכים לשערך. נכון הנון Context של Padding.
אנחנו מצמצמים אותה דרמטית. כן, אוצר המילים נהיה מאוד קטן.
זה נחמד. אנחנו יכולים ללמוד איך משלבים יחד אותיות וללמוד אולי בשאיפה לזהות רצפים דומים.
נגיד, יש כל מיני דברים שמכילים את הפועל א כ. ל כן, אם זה אוכל נאכל אך לא אכלתי וכן הלאה.
הם מתנהגים בצורה דומה, נכון? אז אולי גם זה. אנחנו נותנים פוטנציאלית למודל אפשרויות ללמוד את הקשרים בין מילים כאלה.
מצד שני, יש חסרונות ברורים גם עכשיו האינפוט שלנו הרבה יותר ארוכים.
נכון, זאת אומרת שאנחנו צריכים לדעת לעבוד עם טקסטים הרבה יותר ארוכים ולקשור יחד מילים שמאוד רחוקות אחת מהשנייה.
אז כאילו תחשבו על נגיד Transformer, אנחנו צריכים לעשות attention עכשיו על המון המון דברים.
כן, הרבה יותר מאשר מה שהיה לנו כשנפרדנו לפי לפי רווחים.
וגם אנחנו צריכים בעצם ללמוד מהתחלה. כן from scratch.
איך בעצם לחבר יחד Characters כדי לייצר מילים?
אוקיי, יש הרבה רצפים של Characters שהם לא מילים. אנחנו באיזשהו מובן גם צריכים ללמוד להפריד כדי שנוכל לייצר טקסטים שמכילים מילים אמיתיות בכתיב תקני.
אנחנו איכשהו גם צריכים ללמוד את זה, אבל אם היה לנו מילים שלמות באוצר מילים, בעצם היינו מקבלים את זה בחינם.
נכון, זה הדבר היחידי שהוא יכול לעשות אותו בסדר אז אז זה character left.
אז אמרנו אוקיי, מצד אחד יש לנו את ה split by space עם החסרונות שלו.
נכון Ano words אין הכללה בין מילים כל הדברים האלה.
ויש לנו את ה split by characters שיש לו אוצר מילים קטן.
הכללה בין מילים אבל input סיקוונס אז ארוכים צריך ללמוד לאיית.
צריך לומר שיש גם מקרים שבהם הם באיזשהו מובן יותר הם הם יותר רחוק מקרקר level.
זאת אומרת, הם לא רק שהם מכילים מילים שלמות, הם בעצם גם עשויים להכיל רצפים של מילים כחלק מהותי.
אם הם מספיק נפוצות. כן. אז למשל, זו דוגמה לכל בן Language, מודל שנקרא ג'ורג רק אחד או ג'יי אחד.
אז אלה דוגמאות לאוצר המילים. אז שם היה להם גם חתיכות של מילים.
Word pieces under score זה אומר רווח?
כן, אז גם דברים כמו free או ISM או נס או לא, וגם דברים שהם מילים כמו cat או Description או system out print land.
כן. לא יודע אם מישהו מכם מכיר עוד את המשתמשים בכלל.
עוד בג'אווה. כן בסדר. וגם מולטי Expressions.
כן, כמו טוני סטארק או Marketing campaign או National public radio.
אוקיי, כל עוד זה היה מספיק נפוץ כדי להכניס אוצר מילים, כמובן שהוצאות אוצר המילים במקרים האלה בדרך כלל הרבה יותר גדול מאשר אפילו מאשר הוורד וורד.
והשיטה הפופולרית By Far שהתקבצו אליה רוב הבדלי השפה זה מה שנקרא סאב Word Documentation,
כלומר טוקנים שמכילים או חתיכות של מילים, או לכל היותר מילים שלמות אם הן מספיק נפוצות.
אוקיי, ואני אסביר איך זה עובד. יצא לכם לשמוע על המושג הזה sub words?
לא, לא נתקלתם בו? אוקיי. אז הגישות הכי פופולריות לנושא הזה הן גישות סטטיסטיות, גישות סטטיסטיות לרוב, גישות סטטיסטיות חשדניות.
אני אציג את הסמכות הידועה ביותר מביניהם, ונראה לי גם עדיין הכי פופולרית שזה שיטה שנקראת BPM או בית pair עם Padding,
שזה תולדה של מאמר שכתוב כאן למי שיעניין לקרוא יותר לעומק למשל translation words.
זה די אומץ, כן? אז באמת המטרה הראשונית של צורת התקן הזו הזאת הייתה באמת ההכללה למילים נדירות או ממש?
And words. אוקיי, וספציפית, הם עבדו על זה בהקשר של תרגום.
כאמור, הרבה מהטכנולוגיה של מודלי השפה בעצם. לראשונה התפתחה סביב תרגום דוגמה זו.
Transformer. אוקיי, אז איך עובד הבית עם Coding?
סך הכל אלגוריתם די פשוט. אתם קובעים בהתחלה את גודל אוצר המילים.
אוקיי, בסדר, זה איזשהו פרמטר שאתם צריכים להגדיר מהו.
כמה מילים אתם רוצים? אתם מכניסים לתוך V לתוך אוצר המילים.
אתם מכניסים בהתחלה את כל הכרטיס. אוקיי, אז כל התווים הבודדים שנמצאים הם מקבלים מקום זר.
ההנחה היא ש k הוא לפחות כן מרשה מרשה את זה.
כן, שמספר Characters הוא קטן מ A. ועכשיו אתם עובדים בלולאה.
כן. While. גודל של אוצר המילים קטן שווה.
זאת אומרת עד שמיציתם את הגודל של אוצר המילים. מה אתם עושים?
אתם עושים פרי Token של פרי Token. הכוונה היא זה זה או שזה בדרך כלל או לחלק?
כן, זה משתנה, אבל זה זה. זה להפעיל איזשהו כלל שבעצם כן, זה בעצם להפעיל איזשהו כלל חותך את המילים איזשהו חיתוך ראשוני.
כן. נגיד למשל, לפי White space לא חייבים לעשות את זה.
זה בדרך כלל איזה שהיא סליקה, אבל שמשתמשים בה נגיד כמו להפעיל אחד.
White space based. זה ואנחנו נראה גם דברים אחרים בהמשך.
אז אתם אולי עושים איזשהו כן אחרי processing data ואחרי זה אתם עושים טוקן חציה לדאטה כן לדאטה שאתם עכשיו עובדים עליו.
ההנחה היא שיש לכם איזשהו דאטה שבעזרתו אתם לומדים את התואר חייזר.
כן, ומה שאתם עושים זה בעצם מזהים שם כל פעם את ה long as matching price.
כן. אז מה הכוונה? כן, הכוונה היא שאם אוצר המילים שלכם הוא נגיד בהתחלה פשוט אז Bga אין Psu.
אוקיי, אז בעצם ונניח שאתם עושים Protocol ציה לטקסט לפי white space ומגלים שהמילים זה האג פג פנ בן הגס.
אוקיי, ולפי התדירויות האלה, אז בעצם הצורה שבה אתם תעשו לה טוקנים חציה זה כאילו הצורה הכי מסיבית בסדר.
כלומר אם יש לכם רק Characters אז אין מה לעשות הציור יהיה לפי Character כן Hug.
כן כמו שאתם רואים כאן. אבל אם היה לכם בתוך אוצר המילים גם רצף נגיד כמו למשל כאן היה לכם למשל Ug.
אוקיי, אז לכאורה עכשיו את המילה Hug הייתם יכולים? או לעשות לו כניסה חציה כ Hug או לעשות אורגניזציה כאן Ug.
נכון, שניהם אפשריים על בסיס האבוקדו Larry.
אז אתם לוקחים תמיד את הכיוון המקסימלי סטטי. אוקיי, אתם מנסים כמה שיותר.
כל עוד יש לכם Token שמכיל את כן את, את את ההתחלה של של ה String שאתם מנסים לעשות לו Token ליצירה.
אז אתם ממשיכים? כן, לוקחים כמה שיותר ארוך. אז זה הכוונה כאן?
Taking the long matching traffic count efficiency of all לג'ייסון Token pairs in the data.
אוקיי, אז עכשיו אני מסתכל על כל המילים וכל המילים בעצם כל ה Token כן שקיבלתי ומסתכל על רצפים של טוקנים סמוכים ומוציא freelance list.
אוקיי, בודק מה הכי נפוץ מוצא אותו.
בוא נגיד שנקרא לו LR כן, Token שמשמאל Token מימין.
אז עכשיו אני מוסיף את המרץ Token LR לתוך אוצר המילים.
אז בואו נראה איך זה נראה. זה אלגוריתם מאוד פשוט. כן, סך הכל אתם מתחילים פשוט רק 100 Characters.
נגיד אתם רוצים להגיע ל 10 אז אתם רואים שיש לכם רק 7 כרגע נכון?
עשיתם איזשהו pre animation? קיבלתם הג פג פנ בן האגס?
לא הייתם חייבים לעשות פרי טוק Animation. אגב, הייתם גם יכולים פשוט לקחת הכל כמילה אחת ארוכה או לא משנה מה.
זה פשוט הופך את התהליך לטיפה פחות יעיל. אז בגלל זה בדרך כלל כן מעדיפים לחתוך אותו, אבל זה לא נורא קריטי.
אז אנחנו מסתכלים על BG Npm, שזה השלב הראשון כאן.
צעד מספר 1 עושים לו תו כניסה חציה. אז עכשיו אנחנו מגלים שאנחנו כן.
כל אחד מהמילים האלה עושים ועושים לה את הקונספציה. עכשיו אנחנו מקבלים בעצם טוקנים בודדים.
אנחנו מסתכלים על רצפים סמוכים של Token Token. אם כרגע הם רק האותיות, אז בעצם זה רצפים סמוכים של אותיות ואנחנו רואים מה התדירות.
הופעה של כל זוג. אנחנו בוחרים את הגבוה יותר ביניהם שזה Ug.
אנחנו מוסיפים את ה g לאוצר המילים ועכשיו סליחה, אנחנו חוזרים חזרה למילים שלנו ומתחילים לחלק אותם.
אז עכשיו יש לנו huge plug in כי אין דרך יותר קצרה לעשות את זה וכן הלאה.
ושוב אנחנו מוצאים עכשיו שיהיו פלוס n זה הנפוץ ביותר. אז אנחנו מוסיפים את u פלוס n.
בשלב הבא אנחנו. מה שיקרה זה שהיא מספר יצא שנוסיף את Hug ובשלב הזה כבר יש לנו 10 מילים.
אז אנחנו מה עושים 10 טוקנים? סליחה אז אנחנו עוצרים בסדר וזה עכשיו יהיה שלנו.
אז ככל שגודל אוצר המילים יותר גדול, ככה אנחנו נקבל רצפים יותר ארוכים.
ככל שזה יותר קצר אנחנו נקבל רצפים קצרים יותר.
בדרך כלל לא נותנים לטווח לייזר.
זה משתנה, אבל בין מקרה למקרה, אבל בהרבה מקרים לא נותנים לה Token פייזר לייצר Token שמכילים White Space, כלומר שאיכשהו מחברים.
זאת אומרת, הם כן מכינים White Space, אבל הם לא מכילים חלק, כאילו לא מכילים White Space.
באמצע הם מכילים White Space רק בהתחלה או בסוף, אבל זה גם עניין של קונבנציה.
ויש כאמור מקרים כמו אותו אחד שהראתי קודם שיש לו בהחלט גם white space באמצע.
כן, גם אותו נסתר Cover Society, אבל הוא בדרך כלל רוב הטור יהיה להם רק כאלה וכאלה.
כלומר, עוד דברים מכילים חתיכות של מילים, אולי עם וויט ספייס בהתחלה ובסוף או כאלה שמכילים.
מילים שלמות עם White space בהתחלה או בסוף אבל לא בעץ.
שאלות. יפה.
בסדר. אז כמובן שכדי להימנע מ Words אנחנו חייבים להוסיף את כל ה characters או ה symbols, כולל אימוג'י או כל דבר אחר שאנחנו רוצים שאנחנו רוצים להכניס.
נכון, ראינו קודם את ההאקינג face mode. נכון שנכנס שם לתוך לתוך הזה.
הבעיה עם זה כמובן שיש לפחות ביוני code משהו כמו לפחות נכון.
בטח כבר יש יותר. כן, לפחות נכון לזמן שבו מצאתי את ה reference הזה.
היו שם 138 אלף Token. אני מניח שיש כיום כבר יותר.
אז בעצם מה שקורה זה שאתם כבר מתחילים עם נדוניה של הרבה מאוד טוקנים שכנראה הרבה מהם הם לא כל כך שימושיים.
בוא נודה על האמת, בכמה אותיות Unicode יצא לכם בכלל אפילו להיתקל בחיים אז לכתוב כן.
כנראה שלא כל ה 138 אלף. והשאלה מה אפשר לעשות עם זה?
אז דרך מקובלת להתמודד עם זה זה להשתמש בביטים. אוקיי, אני לא יודע אם אתם מכירים את הבית Encoding.
אתם מכירים את הדברים האלה. זה נראה לי רק לחובבי הז'אנר. בגדול אני אגיד, אני אפתח פה סוגריים.
אני אגיד באופן עקרוני יש שיטות שונות לבצע Encoding באורך קבוע, לרוב באורך קבוע.
כן, זה משתנה, אבל לא משנה באיזה שהוא אורך עצום של לרוב של שיחה אני אתחיל מחדש.
יש כל מיני דרכים שבעזרתם לוקחים את הכנת ה unicode Symbols וכותבים את זה פשוט כרצף של ביטים.
אוקיי, אז בדרך כלל יש לזה. אני לא יודע אם יצא לכם. בטח יצא לכם להיתקל בזה.
לא שנגיד הרבה פעמים מסמנים את זה עם הופכים את זה אחרי זה ASCII אז זה נראה כמו סלאש u ואז כתוב נגיד ארבעה Characters לפעמים XD סמלים.
לא יצא לכם להיתקל לא משנה. בקיצור, יש דרך פשוט לפרק את זה.
כן לפרק את זה מכל אחד. יש לו איזשהו מספר סידורי אוקיי, שאפשר את המספר הסידורי הזה לכתוב כבעייתיים,
ואז אתם פשוט יודעים שחוץ בעצם את ה נגיד Hanging face Token, אתם לא מייצרים כ Token אחד אלא מעץ.
נגיד הוא נגיד שהוא Token מספר 97 1842 באקורדים שאתם משתמשים בו, אז אתם צריכים לייצר אותו בכמה טוקנים שפחות או יותר,
אומרים הראשון אולי יגיד משהו כמו אני עכשיו עומד לייצר unicode character Encoding.
אז זה אחריו יגיד 97 אלף, 700 קילו, 9, 7, 7 וכן הלאה.
כן ואתם ככה תייצרו את המספר שוב לפי צורת הסכמה.
אבל הנקודה היא שיש דרכים לפרק Characters פשוט בייטים שהם מקוד שהם תתי מחרוזות של המחרוזת, מקודדת אותם בתוך כלים ייעודיים.
כן, בדיוק אלה טוקנים יעודיים,
כלומר כדי שלא יהיה איטי בין משהו שהוא התחלה של קידוד של Unicode character נורא נדיר לבין אותו מספר שמופיע פשוט כמספר ואז הוא כן.
אז בקיצור יש את זה. יש גם כל מיני special symbols בגדול LM בגודל.
כן Modes נאמר מודלים פתוחים יחסית, מודלים שנחשבים קלים.
יש בדרך כלל אוצר מילים בסדר גודל של 50 אלף תוקן.
כן, פלוס מינוס 32 עד 64 אלף.
הקופאית היא מודל המודרני עם הקילו החדשים יותר מגיעים למאות אלפי Token, וזה בערך סדר גודל של צרכנים שמדברים.
אם יש שאלות תעצרו אותי. אוקיי, בסדר, יש גם עוד שיטות חוץ מ BPA.
הרעיונות הם בגדול רעיונות דומים. כן, אם נגיד BPA מסתמך על פרי קווינסי נכון.
עלי למצוא זוגות של טוקנים שמופיעים ביחד באופן תדיר ולאחד אותם לתוכן אחד.
אז יש כאלה שיש שיטות כמו נגיד שיטה שנקראת וורלד פיס,
שהרעיון שם זה שזה לא חישוב על בסיס פרי קווינסי וחישוב על בסיס לייק ליהוד שנותן מודל שפה קטן שמשתמשים בו במיוחד עבור התקני סדציה.
כן, אז איכשהו מכניסים לתוך הלופ של התוכנית גם איזשהו מודל שפה קטן ויש Sentence Piece,
שזה עוד איזושהי התקדמות ששם שהוא משהו שאיכשהו משתמשים בו כדי לעשות בעצם לוותר על הפריט הישן ועדיין שהוא יעבוד באופן די יעיל.
וזה טוב לשפות. נגיד כמו סינית שלא כתוב בהם רווחים בין מילים.
אז לפעמים יש רצפים מאוד ארוכים של Characters. שוב אני שם כאן את זה כרפרנס למי שרוצה להרחיב אנחנו לא נדבר עליהם.
ועכשיו עניין נוסף ומעניין אני חושב שזה בכל הסיפור שסיפרתי לכם עכשיו לגבי איך עושים תוכנית סדציה BPA ואמרתי שאפשר גם לא לפי Free Council,
שיטות אחרות וכן הלאה. בגדול כל השיטות האלה מבוססות על סיגנלים סטטיסטיים.
אין שם שום עניין שקשור לניתוח לשוני של השפה בשום דרך.
ועולה השאלה המתבקשת האם באמת כל הידע שיש לנו לגבי מבנה של מילים?
נגיד בעברית נכון, שורש בניין תבנית כן, בערבית גם כנל ופשוט שפות שאני מניח שלפחות עברית, בטח גם ערבית.
בטח חלקכם מכירים, אבל זה קורה בהרבה שפות כי יש לנו די הרבה ידע בלשני לגבי מבנה של מילים.
כן, רצפי מילים. למה לא להשתמש בו? עולה השאלה.
אז זה דיון שהוא עדיין קורה, וככל הנראה או לפחות עד כה.
שפות שיש להן מורפולוגיה יחסית ענייה כמו אנגלית שאין בה סך הכל יותר.
כאילו רוב המורפולוגיה שם היא מה שנקרא Concrete native.
כן, זאת אומרת מילים מתקבלות ממילים אחרות על ידי הוספה של איזושהי מוספת.
כן, כמו נס, נכון? Tired, Tired Ness כן, או כמו לי.
נכון קארד? קארד לי. או כאילו זה בגדול מתבסס על מספיקות ואז יחסית ברור איך משהו כמו BPM.
נכון שמחלק את הכל ל Characters ואז מוסיף יחד Characters שנוטים להופיע ביחד.
איך הדבר הזה יוצר משהו מתקבל על הדעת? כן, אבל יש שפות למשל, כמו עברית, כמו ערבית וגם שפות אחרות שהן לא קונקרטי.
נייטיב כן, שיש מופנמות שהן לא פשוט מתחברות לאיזושהי מוספת להתחלה או לסוף.
והנה דוגמה ממאמר של ממודל שפה Arabic Central הם קוראים לזה.
מה הכוונה? אז כבר היום מאוד נדיר שיש מודלי שפה שהם יוני לינק דואלי לחלוטין.
זאת אומרת שלקחו את כל ה training data סיננו אותו כדי שיהיה אך ורק ספציפית לשפה הזאת.
כי אפילו אם תסתכלו על טקסטים בערבית או בעברית, בדרך כלל הם כן קצת יכילו ולפחות טקסטים לפחות באנגלית.
נכון קצת כן, אולי משפטים פה ושם ביטויים אז בדרך וגם חוץ מזה.
בקיצור, בדרך כלל לא מדברים על יוני language models, אבל כן מדברים על language specific או language contract models,
כשהכוונה היא שרוב ה training data ורוב ההנדסה היא בשביל לשפר ביצועים במקרה הזה בערבית,
אז זה מודל שנקרא פנר, שהם נתנו שם את הדוגמה ואמרו אוקיי, אם אנחנו כשעשינו BPM אי, אז נגיד למשל מילים כמו אל רחמן יש כאן דוברי ערבית.
אוקיי. כן, נכון. אז זה בפרק הפתיחה של הקוראן, אז כנראה בגלל זה הם נתנו את זה כדוגמה לא כל כך משנה, אז אני מצטט את הדוגמה שלהם.
אז בגדול מה שזה זה הרחום כן, בעברית שזה האל העל הזה.
כן, ה שתי אותיות הראשונות זה זה, יידוע נכון והשאר זה פשוט מילה שאומרת רחום שהיא בסדר משורש מסוים אבל לא משנה כרגע.
והבי פי פירק את זה לאל רחמן. אוקיי, עכשיו מן או הוא בעצם או מין.
כן, כי אין כאן ניקוד. הוא בעצם גם מילת יחס. כן, כמו מין בעברית כן.
ואז הם אמרו שזה יצר, שזה בעצם יצר להם כל מיני, לפעמים כל מיני טעויות מוזרות כאלה.
כן, כי בעצם הוא היה צריך להבין שמין הוא כאילו מין הפך להם בידיו.
כן, הוא יכול להיות גם מילת יחס, והוא גם יכול להיות חתיכה אקראית ממילה שבמקרה מכילה את הרצף הדי נפוץ מ.
נ. אוקיי, וכאילו זה הופך את המילה למאוד להורדה BIOS וחבל.
כן, כי הם אמרו, אבל אנחנו הרי יודעים שפשוט מטמורפוזות שקל סגמנטציה ויש כלים לעשות מניפולציה בערבית שזה לא צריך להיות ככה, אלא זה צריך להיות ככה.
כן, אל רחמן. וכנל בעברית.
כן, זו דוגמה למאמר בעברית, אז גם הם יסתכלו על כל מיני.
כן, הם הסתכלו על כל מיני מילים שחרור של שחרור ושחררה.
קש? ושחרורם.
כן. כשביקש שחררנו. טוב אוקיי, בסדר.
וכנראה הם מצאו את זה באיזה קורפוס. כן, כנראה שזה היה כתוב שם.
על כל פנים הם הסתכלו. הם הסתכלו ספציפית על וורלד פיס, אבל הרעיון הוא דומה ל BP.
אז שחרור היה מילה אחת סבבה. שש שחרור הפך לשש שחר.
ובעצם זה סימון של משהו שהוא באמצע מילה.
כן ו ר שמסיים מילה. ושיחררה עבדו לא לא נפרדה.
ה כן, וכשחזרנו הפך ל ש ברור.
ונו? כן. אז בקיצור, כפי שאתם מבינים זה פשוט יצר.
במקרים מסוימים זה היה בסדר נכון כמו אנו או ה.
במקרים אחרים הוא לא עשה עם זה כלום. שאולי זה גם בסדר, אבל זה בעצם מייצר קצת ספר סטטי.
נכון, כי כאילו עכשיו יש לו גם Token ושחרור וגם יש לו Token שחרור ומן הסתם יש לו או יש לו Token גם וחתול וגם Token חתול וכן הלאה וכן הלאה.
נכון? אז חבל. ובנוסף לכל הבעיות האלה, לפעמים הוא גם עושה פוליטיזציה שכנראה על בסיס הסטטיסטיקה היא מתקבלת על הדעת.
אבל זה כאילו נראה כמו נגיד שעכשיו אני אומר לכם ששלושת האותיות הראשונות של המילה שאתם צריכים לנחש הם ו כ ש.
כן זה. זאת אומרת, בסדר, אפשר לבצע את ה דיקציה הזאת, אבל כאילו זה קצת מיותר, נכון?
למה לעשות את זה ככה? אין לזה שום תוכן סמנטי שאפשר להסתמך עליו, ולכן גם כנראה הסטטיסטיקות של זה יהיו מאוד הטרוגניות.
אז מה? בגדול כל השיטות האלה עושות? הן עושות משהו בסגנון של למשל מורף BPA.
זו דוגמה אחת זה מאותו מאמר של פנר. Arabic Sentence.
כן. אז הרעיון הוא סך הכל מאוד דומה. Initiative עוקב הילרי ו individual characters.
נכון, זה היה לנו גם קודם. השלב השני זה כבר עכשיו שלב מעניין.
Segment the training corpus using political segment nation.
אוקיי, כלומר תפרידו את האל מ הרחמן נחמן נווה.
תפרידו את ה ו ושחרור ו ה ואת ה וכו ושחרור וכן הלאה.
אז תבצעו איזה שהוא סוג של מופע logical segment. ועכשיו תחזרו כל פעם ותמצאו את הבית Preferences ותעשו Merge.
אבל תכניסו את ה Modified step הזה כאן! Find the most recent byte pair that does not cross מורפין but there is.
אוקיי, כלומר הם לא. אפילו אם.
כן התהליך הזה יראה שבעצם ו ש זה Token זה סליחה.
זה סדרה די נפוצה. אוקיי, טוב, זה כבר שלשה.
אבל נגיד וכן נגיד סדרה נפוצה הוא לא יוכל לשם זה להסתמך על המקרים שבהם הם מהווים שתי מרפאות נפרדות.
כלומר, כדי לאחד את ו כ יצטרך לקרות המצב שבו וכו שמהוות חלק מאותה מרפאה,
מה שמהוות חלק מאותו חתיכה לפיה מופעלות על סגמנטים של מודל הם מספיק נפוצים אוקיי,
ולא יורשה בעצם ליהנות כן ממקרים שבהם וכו נרשמו כקו רצף, כי זה בעצם שילוב יחסית נפוץ של שתי מרפאות כמו וכה בסדר.
כן, בעצם כל תוכן שאני רוצה להוסיף אני צריך לבדוק שהוא לא עובר על הגבלת אורולוג.
אבל אז תשים לב. זה לא שאסור לי כאילו אז זה משהו טיפה עדין.
כן, אתה צריך, אתה אוסף לגביו סטטיסטיקות רק על סמך המקרים שבהם הוא לא חוצה גבול של יחידה מורפולוגית.
אוקיי, אז כלומר, בסדר, בוא נגיד שיש לך.
אני לא יודע מה. אה? מבוך כן.
אמרתי כן ושחרור לא זה לא טוב.
וכשחזרתי whatever וראיתי וכן הלאה וכן הלאה.
אוקיי, ועכשיו אתה עכשיו יש לך נגיד בהתחלה רק Characters.
אוקיי, אז כאילו אתה בשלב הראשון. אז עכשיו כל Character הוא Token בפני עצמו.
בסדר. עכשיו אתה רק מריץ מופע לוגיקה לסגמנט Model מופעלת שכל סגמנט של מודל אומר לך אז זה מרפא מאחת.
כן, אלה באו ונסמן את זה אולי בצבע אחר. זה מרפא מחט זה מרפא.
השנייה זה מרפא. השלישי זה מרפא. הרביעית זה אולי מרפא.
החמישית כן, זה. ראשונה זה שנייה.
זה שלישית. אולי ככה, נגיד. אוקיי, אז זה מה שיגיד לך מהרופא Logical Model?
ועכשיו אתה בעצם? אתה בעצם יכול עדיין עקרונית לאחד את ו כ.
כן, כי הם לפעמים כן מופיעים יחד בתוך אותה מרפא, אבל לא ייספרו לעניין זה.
בשביל זה הם צריכים להיות הרצף הכי נפוץ. כן, אז זה לא ייספר ו כ שלוש פעמים ייספר רק פעם אחת, ואת זה אני אעבור על כל המילים לחלק אותם לפי פונולוגיה.
ואחרי זה החלוקה מורפולוגית. זה יהיה המילים שלי ועל בסיס זה אני אעשה אופטימיזציה.
כן, בדיוק. אוקיי.
בסדר, אז אוקיי, עוד שאלות לגבי זה.
אבל צריך לומר שכן. אולי אם אני אוסיף ככה כאיזו שהיא הערה.
בגדול טוקינג סדציה או מורפולוגיה מורפולוגיה סגמנטציה של Models.
כאילו תחשבו שאתם עכשיו איזושהי חברה הנדסית שרוצה לייצר מודלי שפה שעובדים ב 100 שפות.
זה כנראה גם מעבר ליעילות. אולי כן.
לחוזק כן, לכאילו לביצועים שמובילים לכם שיטות סטטיסטיות כמו BPA.
כנראה שזו שיטה שהיא גם יותר קוסמת בהרבה מקרים, פשוט כי היא שיטה שאפשר להפעיל בדיוק את אותה חתיכת קוד,
לא משנה איזו שפה, לא צריך להבין איזו שפה זה, לא צריך לבדוק אם יש על המורפולוגיה גם סגמנטציה של מודל.
לא צריך לעשות שום דבר. כן?
אז תזכרו שגם הרבה פעמים הפרקטיקה המקובלת לא נובעת מזה שניסו גם ככה וגם ככה, ועם סגמנטציה מודל א ו ב וג ובלי ועם BP ועם וורדפרס,
אלא פשוט שגם עשו משהו שיחסית קל לעשות לו Deployment, מהיר ושלא דורש משאבי פיתוח נרחבים מדי.
אוקיי, אז אם לסכם את הפרק הזה, מה הוא Essential?
כאילו פרי processing הכרחי? בוודאי. בשביל נוירו Language Models.
יש כל מיני שיטות שמשתמשים בהם או כל מיני גישות.
יש כשאפשר לומר בקיצור האחד נמצא גישות שמבוססות על Characters בודדים.
למעשה, יש גם גישות יותר רדיקליות שעובדות עם ביטמן. כן, כאילו אומרים חבל להסתכל על Characters בודדים.
אם אני מסתכל בייחוד על כתב יד כן או על פונטים גם כתב זה.
אבל כאילו פונט? בעצם יש מידע שאני זורק בזה שאני הופך את זה לטקסט סטנדרטי ליוני Code, נכון?
עדיף לי לייצג את זה כתמונות בעצם ולעשות אותו כניסה חציה בעצם ברמת התמונות של תווים.
אוקיי, אז גם יש אפילו גישות כאלה, אבל זה יחסית נדיר.
אבל כל פנים בוודאי character level ויש כאלה שאפילו מכילים מולטי Word Expressions.
שימוש בביט הוא מאוד נפוץ, אבל בשפות שיש בהן non concrete native מורפולוגי.
הרבה פעמים משתמשים בסגמנט במעורפל logical segment.
ומה שמאוד חשוב לומר כאן זה שבדרך כלל השיטות נהיות יותר קריטיות ככל שכמות הדאטה שיש לכם היא יותר קטנה.
אוקיי, והסיבה לזה היא שבעצם אם תחשבו על זה, שאלת אותו כמה יהיה גדול אוצר המילים שלכם?
כן, לעומת כן, מה יהיה האורכים של של הסיקוונס?
במילים אחרות כמה אתם רוצים לחלק כמה שיותר וככה להקטין את גודל אוצר המילים ולאפשר הכללה לבין מקרה מקרים שאתם רוצים להגדיל את גודל אוצר המילים.
בעצם ולאפשר פחות הכללה. אבל מצד שני לייצר סיקוונס ים יותר קצרים.
כל טקסט יחולק ללפחות טוקנים. וכל טקסט יחולק לפחות טוקנים.
סליחה, בלבלתי את עצמי. אם מצד אחד יש לכם את.
אני אחזור על זה. אם מצד אחד יש לכם את הקריקטורה level.
כאילו היתרון שבו זה שמאל עוקביו larry side כן שמאלה, עוקביו Larry אבל.
Long sick. כן, שמאל עוקביו לרי. Generally nation.
Across words. ונגיד הווארד level או אפילו המולטי word level ובוודאי world level זה Shorter כן, אז Larger בוקר.
ולס ג'נרל. אבל מצד שני. מצד שני.
No need. To learn how to spell.
אז אם יש לכם הרבה מאוד data, אז כנראה אתם תסתדרו.
כך או כך או כך. כן, זה קצת שאלה. איפה זה קצת שאלה טכנית?
איפה יותר יכאב לכם? האם הסיקוונס עם הארוכים או שעבור אוצר מילים גדול אתם איכשהו תצטרכו לנווט את זה, אבל כנראה שכך או כך תצליחו להסתדר עם זה.
הבעיה היא שכשיש לכם יחסית מעט דאטה, שם אתם כבר נמצאים.
בסד אילוצים הרבה יותר קשה, כי מצד אחד אולי אתם רוצים אוצר מילים שהוא לא מאוד גדול.
כן, כי שוב, אין לכם הרבה דאטה. מצד שני אתם מקבלים רצפים יותר ארוכים, אז יש לכם איזושהי בעיה שם?
אם יש לזה מורפולוגיה יותר עשירה, אולי אתם כן רוצים לפצל?
כי אתם רוצים ליהנות מהמכללה בין הקריטריונים, אבל אם אין מורפולוגיה כל כך עשירה,
אז אולי אתם רוצים לא כל כך לפצל, כי ממילא אין הרבה מה ללמוד מהצורה שבה מילים שונות כתובות.
כן, אין כל כך מה ללמוד ממילה אחת לשנייה,
ואז כנראה תצטרכו הרבה יותר להיזהר ולראות איפה בדיוק כן הנקודה הכי כואבת ואיך לעשות שימוש בדאטה בצורה אופטימלית.
וכאן הרבה פעמים התעסקות יותר עדינה בתקני סדציה הופכת להיות מאוד משמעותית, ממש הכרחית כדי לבנות מערכות שעובדות בצורה סבירה.
זהו. זאת הייתה ההערה האחרונה ובואו נצא להפסקה וניגש לנושא האחרון אחריה.
המושג הזה יוצא מן הכלל. כן, זהו, אני חשבתי שהתוכנית לא.
הכנתי את זה אבל לא העליתי. לא הייתי בטוח. אתה יודע, זה נהיה שם.
עכשיו אני אשים את זה פה, אני אעלה אותה. כן.
כן. כן.
אין לי שום דבר. אני לא רוצה שום.
דבר אחר לא הצלחתי.
עכשיו. אני?
חייב שנייה. לא רוצה להתאמץ. בכל זאת.
צריך לעשות משהו קצת? יותר טוב?
השלב הבא ממש. בשבוע הבא.
כן כן, אז יש עוד קשר חזרה. אמרתי לך כן.
לא? סתם.
כן. יהיה פה בהצלחה. טוב. אז עכשיו זה הנושא החברתי בקורס?
בעצם יש לך? כאילו אם אמרת לו ששבוע הבא זה חזרה.
אז עכשיו זה בעצם הנושא האחרון? כן כן. אני עושה קצת.
סדר. זה נוער אצלי שזה בשלישי הבא עם הקבוצה החמישי כדי.
להבין את הליגה מתחדשת, אבל אני חושב שזה.
לא יהיה פשוט. חשוב.
שאלה. המבחן בקורס אבטחת מידע ממוחשב.
קצת. על מה היה המבחן בקורס?
על מה יהיה בקורס? כל החומר פשוט ידע, שיעורים, תרגילים.
יש שאלות פתוחות או צפויים. אני אישית לא אהיה מופתע אם זה יהיה באותו פורמט בדיוק כמו שהיו משנים קודמות.
בסוף נעלה אותו עם כל החברים. אפשר לחשוב שאם.
כן, בגיל שהצגת אז אמרנו שבעצם לוקחים את המילים ואחרי זה אנחנו כאילו ממש מפרטים כאילו מבטאים אותם כאילו לפי רפלקסים שלנו.
נכון שזה היה כאילו לחלקים שלהם בהתחלה מפרקים אותם לאותיות ואז מתחילים להפחיד יחד אותיות
שמופיעות יחד קודם מפרקים לאותיות ואז כאילו מתחילים אתה כל פעם מפרק לפי אוצר המילים הקיים.
כן, אבל בצורה מקסימלית. כלומר שאם יש לך נגיד מילה שמתחילה ב B ואחרי u יש לך גם Token B וגם Token ביום אז מה עדיף?
ומה הגבול של זה שזה לא יהיה לאורך כל הטקסט?
כאילו הרווחים או משהו בדרך כלל חוסמים את זה ברווחים, אבל גם תזכור שזה לא יהיה לאורך כל הטקסט, פשוט כי אלא אם כל הטקסט חוזר הרבה פעמים.
לא, אבל אני מתכוון נניח. אני מאמין שיגיעו בטקסט, אבל נניח בטקסט האות הראשונה שלו זה A ועוד האחרונה זה זבל.
אז איך אני יודע שאחד לא יודע כביכול פרפקט זה כולל גם כל הטקסט עצמו.
פשוט כאילו אלא אם כן יהיה רווחים באמצע לא הייתי ברור.
נכון? לא נכון. אמרנו שיכול להיות לך באיוב באמצע.
אז אמרתי אז למה שלא יהיה לי פשוט את כל הטקסט שנניח כל הטקסט מתחיל ונגמר בזה?
כאילו אם אין רווחים בכלל אז כאילו אתה כאילו ממש תראה את כל התווים הבודדים.
ואז תראה את כל המילים שמורכבות משתי אותיות ואז משלוש אותיות.
וככה עד שתגיע לכל הטקסט עצמו רק הנפוצות ביותר, מה רק הנפוצות ביניהן.
נכון. הרי אז זה אה, בגלל הראשון, כי אתה תמיד אתה עובד גרידי.
אתה כל פעם לוקח רק את הזוג שהוא הכי נפוץ ביחד, אתה מקבץ אותו ביחד ואז עושה את זה מחדש.
ואז כאילו הבנתי אם אני ארצה להגיע ל שלוש אותיות אז אני אתקדם עם בי איקס, נניח כן ולא עם בי דאבליו.
אם יש לך נגיד אם כדי להגיע לפיט X קודם היה צריך להיות לך טוב.
כן, בדיוק כפי שאתה מתחבר עם X מאוד טוב של UX שמחבר יהודי.
אני כאילו תמיד לוקח בכל שלב התחלתי נפוצות רק אז כאילו ואז אתה עושה מחדש לוקליזציה.
על סמך זה כל פעם אתה מגדיל את גודל אוצר המילים באחד כל איטרציה.
אז כאילו בהתחלה אני מתחיל אז עדיין יהיה לי את כל את כל התווים הבודדים.
נכון, יהיה לי את כל התווים, מה שבכלל לא ייצא. כבר יהיה לי את כל התווים הבודדים, אבל יהיה לי רק אחד בגודל 2 או רק אחד בגודל 3.
חתיכת בגודל 4 אז אחד בגודל החדש. אז איך הגענו לקטע המורפולוגי אחרי זה שאמרנו שיש בעיה שיכול להיות שזה ימצא את הענין בערבית?
כי למה לא? אה, כי כי אין לו שום. הוא אדיש לחלוטין לשאלה.
אז איך האלגוריתם המורפולוגי עובד בעצם? ראיתי ש.
לא כל כך נכנסנו לזה, אבל הנקודה היא שהוא אמור לתת לך איזושהי סגמנטציה מורפולוגית.
אוקיי, אז אז בעצם מה שקורה זה שאם אתה לא לוקח בחשבון עצם מורפולוגי, אז בעצם יכול להיות שאתה.
בעצם. כל פעם שיש לך זוג תור כנס שהם אולי נמצאים במרפאות שונות, הם נחשבים לספירה כמו זוג של טוקן שנמצאים בתוך אותם רופאים ולכן הם מועמדים יותר טובים.
ונגיד שתחשוב על זה אם במקרה של השחרור כן שהיה שם אז כאילו אם יש לך הרבה ממה שזה לא היה רק ששחררנו או משהו כזה אז אם אז ואז.
הכף ושין הם לא אוהביו כבשר ששחררנו.
הם לא כל אחד הוא בפני עצמו. נכון, יש ביניהם בלדרים או ארכיאולוגים, אז בעצם זה מאוד מקטין את הסיכון שיווצר לך דווקא כמו מה שלא היה שם.
ווו כף ש. כן, כי כדי שזה ייווצר זה צריך להיות רצף שהוא נפוץ בתוך גופא מעטפת שמקיפה מעבר של זה.
זה איזושהי יחידה. אתה יכול לחשוב על זה כמין חידה של שיש לה איזושהי משמעות או שיש לה?
דיברנו על זה קצת בפרק על גרנד, כי הוא משהו שיש לו תפקיד עצמאי מבחינת דקדוק,
נגיד כמו ויו החיבור כמו מילות יחס כמו הקטנה, כמו הטייה של פועל רבים כן וכן הלאה.
כן. אפשר?
לעשות? עסקים? זה?
לא מספיק. אילו שאלות נוספות במקרה. שלך.
אילו שאלות על נסיעות לחול? מזל. טוב.
אני לא יודע להתחייב על זה. כן נכון. כן, את לא יודעת.
אפילו לא התחלנו ב 31 ביולי. לדעתי כן.
אוקיי, אז יש לי את זה. לא, לא פספסתי את הדדליין. בסדר.
אוקיי, אז זה בסדר. אז זה בסדר?
גמור. טוב, נמשיך.
אז נושא אחרון שאני רוצה שנדון בו זה בעצם נושא שנגע בו ממש על קצה המזלג והוא הנושא של אנליזה סמנטית וספציפית information Expression.
ואני אסביר למה הכוונה. זה אחד האפליקציות, אני חושב, לפחות היסטורית.
אחת האפליקציות היותר מרכזיות של NLP, ועדיין כזאת שיש לה הרבה מאוד שימוש ועניין בתעשייה, באקדמיה וכולי.
אז מה הרעיון ב information expression? בגדול, הרעיון ב information section שאנחנו רוצים לקחת an structure.
טקסט כן, פשוט טקסטים שהורדנו אולי יחד עם Markup או משהו כזה.
אבל בגדול טקסטים שהורדנו נגיד מרחבי הווב או מאיזשהו ארכיון או משהו כזה שהם נמצאים בצורה לא מסודרת,
מאורגנת ולהפוך אותם ל Structure Information למשל Relations Database או לא יודע איזשהו פורמט מוסכם של ג'ייסון או מה שזה לא יהיה כן,
אבל הכוונה היא דברים שלגביהם אנחנו, שאנחנו יכולים לנתח אותם או יכולים לשלוף מהם או יכולים לעשות עליהם חיתוכים ומרגשים וכן הלאה,
באמצעות כלים סטנדרטיים של מסדי נתונים.
יצא לכם להיתקל קצת במסדי נתונים בתואר שהם הקשרים?
זה קורס חובה עדיין או שכבר לא? לא, אבל כמובן שמבחינת חובת בחירה.
אוקיי, אבל לפחות את המושג Relation על Database יצא לכם לשמוע שכן school לא יודע דברים כאלה.
כן? אוקיי, בסדר. אז בדרך כלל השלב הראשון כשרוצים לעשות information extractor זה לעשות identity recognition משימה שאנחנו כבר מכירים.
בגדול נכון, הרעיון שם זה לזהות שמות, שמות פרטיים של ארגונים, אנשים, יחידות גיאוגרפיות.
לא יודע מה דתות, מבנים וכולי וכולי.
הנקודה היא שזה שמות פרטיים של דברים name entity ולמצוא מה הגבולות שלהם ומה הקטגוריה שלהם.
אז זו משימה שכבר הצורה שמבצעים אותה כבר דיברנו עליה, אבל כן, הרעיון הוא מוכר.
אנחנו רוצים לזהות שמות כמו יונייטד איירליינס או טים וואגנר, או שיקגו או דאלאס ו דנבר ולסווג אותם.
נגיד בסכמה המאוד פשוטה הזאת זה פרסום ו location.
ככלל, לפעמים משתמשים בהרבה יותר קטגוריות יכולות מאות קטגוריות שונות, תלוי בהקשר יפה.
אחרי שזיהינו את השמות, אנחנו בעצם רוצים לעשות קורא French resolution.
כלומר, אנחנו רוצים לזהות את כל המופעים השונים של אותו השם בטקסט.
כן, אז למשל יכול להיות. יונייטד איירליינס.
יונייטד איירליינס יופיע אחרי זה בטקסט, למשל בתור יונייטד או TIM Wagner.
יכול להיות שיופיע אחרי זה? אני לא חושב שבמקרה הזה זה מופיע, אבל יופיע אחרי זה.
נגיד בתיאור היא נכון, הוא בעברית וכן הלאה.
אז ככלל, בהחלט יכול להיות שיש שמות שלעיתים כן עם טקסט מדבר על מישהו.
לא יודע מה נשיא ארצות הברית,
אז אולי לפעמים כתוב נשיא ארצות הברית ולפעמים כתוב טראמפ ולפעמים כתוב מיסטר טראמפ ולפעמים כתוב דונלד טראמפ וכן הלאה וכן הלאה.
כן, זה יכול להיות כל מיני צורות, יכול להיות כל מיני מופעים והיינו רוצים בעצם לחלק אותם למחלקות שקילות.
השלב הזה נקרא קורא French resolution למצוא איזה entity, איזה ישויות בטקסט, איזה חתיכות טקסט מתייחסות לאותו לאותה היישות הסמנטית.
השלב הבא על גבי זה זה לנסות למצוא יחסים בין אותם ישויות כן וליצור יחסים בין אותם ישויות.
מהם אותם יחסים? זה משתנה לפי ההקשר.
זה משתנה לפי היישום, אבל יחסים יכולים להיות מהרבה מאוד סוגים.
למשל, במקרה של טקסטים עסקיים כאלה, או במקרה שאנחנו רוצים לעשות אינפורמיישן אקסטרה אקשן.
עם מוטיבציה כזאת של אתם יודעים של business intelligence או דברים כאלה, אז כנראה נרצה למצוא דברים כמו מי שכר את מי,
מי פיטר את מהתפקיד של כל אחד, איזה יחידה היא יחידת בת של יחידה אחרת וכל מיני דברים שרלוונטיים לעולם העסקים.
במקרים אחרים זה יהיה דברים אחרים. אז מה שאנחנו בעצם צריכים להגדיר זה מה שנקרא אונטולוגיה של יחסים, כי אנחנו בעצם צריכים להגדיר איזשהו אוסף של יחסים.
הרבה פעמים גם יהיה איזשהם יחסים. בעצם יהיה יחסים בין היחסים.
כלומר יהיו יחסים ותתי סוגים של יחסים ולפעמים תתי תתי סוגים של יחסים וכן הלאה.
אבל הנקודה היא ש האונטולוגיה מגדירה את אוסף היחסים הסגמנטים שאותם היינו רוצים לייצג.
אוקיי, חלקם יהיו אולי מאוד כלליים כמו Person Social.
אוקיי, שאולי יתחלקו לתתי קטגוריות כמו Family Business, Listing Professional Listing Personal וכן הלאה.
אולי גם אישי, ארעי, לא יודע מה רומנטי וכולי וכולי.
כן physical ופורט הול וכן הלאה.
זה ליחסים מאוד אבסטרקטיים ובדרך כלל יתפרקו לכן תתי חלקים.
כפי שציינו קודם. אז נגיד או Generation ואפילו nation אולי יתחלק ליחסים Founder owner members sports Affiliates.
Employee by student aloni.
איפה הבן אדם למד בתור סטודנט ו investor in וכן הלאה וכן הלאה.
נגיד. דוגמאות ל partial relations ראינו גם בטקסט הקודם יונייטד איזה unit of Visual Corp American איזה unit of.
עכשיו מה שמה? אחד הדברים שחשוב להדגיש זה שכל אחד מהיחסים האלה כמובן.
סליחה ונדבר על זה עוד בהמשך. כל אחד מהיחסים האלה יכול להיות מוסבר על ידי הרבה צורות טקסטואליות שונות, נכון?
נגיד למשל, אם אני אומר שמישהו הוא עובד באיזושהי חברה, כן יחס של Employment נכון,
אז יכול להיות שיהיה כתוב שהוא Employee ביי או שאיי בי אם employees X או Axis employee By.
וגם יכול להיות שיירשמו X works for IBM.
נכון או לא יודע, X served as a senior engineering fell in IBM.
שמזה נגזר שהוא גם עובד. אבל זה משהו יותר ספציפי וכן הלאה וכן הלאה.
נכון, יש הרבה מאוד דרכים שונות שבהן היחס הזאת יכול.
זה יכול להיות מרובע, וזה כמובן אחד הדברים שהופכים את המשימה הזאת למשימה מאתגרת באופן כללי.
אוקיי, ככלל המטרה שלנו. או דרך אחת אבסטרקטית לחשוב על זה שמה שאנחנו בעצם מייצרים כאן זה איזושהי כן איזושהי איזשהו מודל.
כאילו במובן של לוגיקה. כאילו מודל הכוונה היא שאנחנו בעצם מייצרים איזושהי סמנטיקה פורמלית למה שכתוב בטקסט.
אנחנו בעצם מזהים מי הם הישויות השונות.
כן, מהו הדומיין? כן. אוסף כל הישויות שניתן לדבר עליהן.
מהן הישויות שיש להן שם פרטי? כן, כמו יונייטד, אמריקן איירליינס וכן הלאה.
אנחנו אולי אנחנו רוצים לזהות אולי טיפוסים של הישויות האלה, כי ככלל יש לנו כמה טיפוסים.
נכון, כמו אורגניזם ישן Person location. או דברים הרבה יותר ספציפיים כמו Building the Name of the זיז וואטאבר.
כן, תלוי בהקשר ויחסים ביניהם, שאולי הם בינאריים טריינרים וכל סדר, כל סדר שהוא.
בסדר. אז כאמור, יש כל מיני אנתולוגיות שונות ומשונות, חלקן עדינות יותר, עדינות פחות והן משתנות לפי הצורך.
אז דוגמה נוספת שבעצם דוגמה נוספת שאני רוצה לתת לכם שהיא אולי קצת יותר ספציפית זה היא Mls היונייטד medical language system.
כן, שזה איזשהו רעיון שבו כן.
אז כפי שאתם יודעים, דוחות טיפוליים דוחות של בית חולים כן של פרוצדורות, של אשפוזים, של ביקורים במרפאה ככלל כתובים בשפה טבעית.
הרבה פעמים יש להם גם רכיבים של לבחור קטגוריות וכדומה, אבל יש שם חלק משמעותי.
חלק משמעותי מהאינפורמציה נתון בשפה טבעית. כן, בתור שכזה יש הרבה מאוד וריאציה באיך אנשים כותבים הם יכולים.
נגיד הם יכולים לציין אולי אחד מכמה שמות שונים שיש למחלה. אולי הם יציינו תת סוג של מחלה, אבל חשוב לנו להבין שזה תת סוג של משהו אחר.
יכולים לציין כל מיני סוגים של יחסים כמו שמשהו מפריע למשהו.
אם ג'רי מסוג מסוים מפריע לפיזיולוגיה של function מסוג אחר.
נכון, כמו למשל לא יודע מכה יבשה מפריעה לתנועה חופשית של הברך או כל דבר אחר שהוא.
ולכן יש חשיבות כדי לעשות data analysis כדי לייצר תקשורת בין מערכות שונות.
ותזכרו שיש הרבה מדינות שהן במובן הזה במצב הרבה פחות טוב מישראל, במובן הזה שיש כמה מערכות נתונים שונות.
נכון, בארצות הברית ככלל בית החולים הוא עובד עם איזושהי, לפחות כך שמעתי עם איזשהו Ensure, עם איזשהו מבטח רפואי.
ועכשיו אם אתם מגיעים לבית חולים שלא עובד איתו אחד או שכזה, אז כנראה שההסכמה לא תתאים.
הקטגוריות יהיו אחרות לגמרי. כן.
בקיצור, יש הרבה עניין ולנסות לעשות סדר, ואחת הדרכים לעשות את זה היא למפות אונטולוגיה שתייצר בעצם משהו שהוא Structure, שאפשר לתרגם אותו בצורות שונות,
שאפשר לעשות לו סטנדרטיזציה שאפשר לחפש עליו, סטטיסטיקות שאפשר לחפש מקרים דומים שקרו באותו המקום שאפשר לנטר וכן הלאה וכן הלאה.
אוקיי, יפה. אוקיי,
מאז שוויקיפדיה נכנסה ובעצם הפכה להיות משאב כל כך משמעותי באופן כללי וספציפית ב AI
כן ב AI כל מודלי השפה בעצם לפחות שאני מכיר עושים שימוש מאוד מאסיבי בוויקיפדיה.
זה אחד הדברים הראשונים שמאמנים עליהם, ובדרך כלל גם על חתיכת טקסט שעושים עליה הכי הרבה אפקטים, הכי הרבה מעברים.
אז בעצם הויקיפדיה מגדירה בצורה מפורשת איזשהו סוג של סכמה.
כן, איזשהו סוג של אונטולוגיה, שגם אם היא לא שומרת עליה בצורה תמיד לגמרי סטרייטית.
כמו כן, כמו בחלק מהמקרים הקודמים שראינו, עדיין סך הכל היא היא מצד אחד עשירה,
מצד שני יש הרבה דוגמאות והיא גם סך הכל די מדוייקת בלפחות בערכים שהם מספיק פופולריים.
כן? אז למה אני מתכוון? אולי אתם ראיתם את הדברים האלה הרבה פעמים בתוך דפי וויקיפדיה מופיע info Boxes כאלה.
כן, אני מציע שיצא לכם מניח שיצא לכם לראות נכון? בעצם אתם יכולים לחשוב על זה כמשהו שכן מגדיר ה Bold Face Fields בעצם מגדירים אונטולוגיה של יחסים.
נכון, במקרה כאן היישות בראד פיט נכון היישות בראד פיט זה לקוח מאתר הויקיפדיה שלו.
יש עליו כל מיני דברים. נכון למשל יש הוא משתתף ביחס Born עם בסדר ויש לו גם כל מיני דברים כאן שזה השם birth name.
התאריך השם של מיקום שהוא עצמו גם entity בויקיפדיה.
כן, אתם רואים את ההיפר לינק אז בעצם זה כבר יחס בינארי.
נכון, זה כבר יחס בין שתי ישויות בוויקיפדיה. שוני אוקלהומה.
ובראד פיט. Occupation כן.
Works שוב זה יחס דו מקומי בין בראד פיט לפיל דמוגרפי שגם הוא Entity בוויקיפדיה Home Town Space או במקרה הזה Species וכולל תתי שדות.
כן, בתוך היחס שהם השנה של נישואים ובמקרים הרלוונטיים פרידה או גירושין, כן relative וכולי וכולי.
עכשיו הדבר הזה הוא בעצם משמש בהרבה מאוד הקשרים בשביל information expression,
פשוט כי זה משאב מאוד נרחב, פתוח לגמרי לציבור וכאמור שנמצא בשימוש מאוד מאוד מאסיבי ב AI.
אני לא יודע אם אתם מכירים את האתר wiki data, שבעצם הוא הוא אתר שמבוסס על ויקיפדיה, אבל נותן ממש לראות את הדאטה בייס לכשעצמו.
כן, זאת אומרת, אתם מכירים את זה? יצא לכם לא? אז שווה לכם להסתכל.
אני אפתח את זה כאן שתראו. כן.
אז Wiki data זה בעצם אתר של בעצם knowledge base שנמצא בבסיס ויקיפדיה, אז יש לו 122 מיליון ערכים.
אוקיי, זה מרשים מאוד ואתם יכולים לחפש בו כל מיני entity.
כן, לכל entity יש ID כאילו יוניק ID.
כן, אז נגיד למשל בראד פיט. אם אתם מסתכלים על בראד פיט, כמובן שיש.
ככלל, הסיבה שיש לו יוניק ID זה כמובן כי יש ככלל כמה אנשים שקוראים להם באותו שם.
נכון, יש גם מתאגרף אוסטרלי. לא יודע אם ידעתם את זה.
כן, אני לא ידעתי, אבל בסדר. נכון, יש שם של ציור של קולין דייוידסון.
יכול להיות אפילו שזה ציור של בראד פיט, אבל זה לא ממש משנה.
זה עדיין ישות נפרדת. על כל פנים, בראד פיט המוכר. American Actor and Film Maker הוא יישות מספר 35 132 בוויקי Data ויש עליו כל מיני פרטים.
יש. יש לו בעצם עוד דבר מעניין ביישות הזאת זה שבאופן עקרוני הישות הזאת אין לה שפה.
כן, היא לא בשפה מסוימת אתם רואים? יש לה מופעים לעשות בראד פיט.
יש בעצם 127 articles בוויקיפדיה בשפות שונות שמתאימות לה.
אוקיי, אז במובן הזה זה איזה שהיא אבסטרקציה גם מעבר לשפה וכמובן קשרים עם יחידות אחרות עם ישויות אחרות כמו ג'ניפר אניסטון,
שוני, אוקלהומה, גווינית פלטרו וכן הלאה וכן הלאה.
אוקיי, הנה, ויש לכם גם כל מיני דברים מאוד מעניינים כמו Instance of Human Part of בראנג'לינה וכל מיני דברים כאלה.
אז יש פה עושר גדול של מידע. יפה.
רגע, איפה אני? כן? בואו נחזור אחורה. כן.
בקיצור, אפשר לעשות עם זה הרבה מאוד מחקר ולהשתמש בזה ולהשתמש בזה להרבה דברים.
אמממ. אוקיי. בהרבה מקרים בעצם אנחנו.
אנחנו היינו רוצים להשתמש בשיטות and Supervision להשתמש בשיטות לא מפוקחות כדי לחלץ נתונים מטקסט,
והסיבה לזה היא ברורה כי מצד אחד יש המון Relations שונים שעקרונית היינו אנחנו עשויים להתעניין בהם נכון?
אז לתייג? נראה מאמץ די משמעותי והם פרוסים על פני הרבה Domains כל אחד מהם.
יש הרבה צורות שונות שניתן להביע אותו. נכון, דיברנו על זה.
בקיצור נראה כאב ראש או לא. ברור שזה משהו יותר מדי פיזי בלי לעשות את זה בצורה מפוקחת.
כן לתייג המון המון Data ולכן התחילו כבר מימיו הראשונים של ה NLP הסטטיסטי לנסות לחשוב על שיטות לא מפוקחות.
השיטה הזאת היא שיטה של מרטי הרסט מ 1992, שהיא עדיין שיטה אפקטיבית.
והרעיון כאן זה להגדיר כל מיני Patterns. כן, כל מיני תבניות שגם משתמשות במילים וגם משתמשות בתחביר.
הרבה פעמים אז הן דורשות איזשהו פרי Processing תחבירי שבעצם Instance.
ואז זה לחפש Instance ים של התבניות האלה ומתוך Instance ים של התבניות ללמוד על היחס.
אוקיי, אז לדוגמה, אם אתם מוצאים בטקסט חופשי, כן, זה טקסט טקסט.
דברים כמו NLP, NLP, NLP and או other NLP.
אוקיי. כמו למשל Temple Structures and other important Civic Buildings.
אז מכאן אולי ניתן להסיק ש. אולי זה גורם לך להגיע רחוק?
בדיוק? כן. שהם מקדשים? כן.
איך זה נקרא בעברית Resources? בתי הוצאה Whatever הם סוגים של בניינים אזרחיים ושירות LG.
מה לגבי NP such as NP ואולי עוד כמה כמו Red, LG such as גלידה.
אז גלידה הוא סוג של אנטי? בדיוק. ואת זה אתה יודע, למרות שאולי גם אם לא היית יודע שמראש שזה סוג של אצה אדומה.
כן. European countries, especially French England and spain. אתם מבינים את הרעיון?
כן. אז זו שיטה אחת שהיא שיטה פשוטה, אבל מסתבר שמאוד חזקה ויכולה גם לעבוד בהרבה שפות שונות אם מזהים את הפטרונים המתאימים.
שיטות מודרניות יותר הרחיבו את זה, ואז הם בעצם לא התעסקו רק ולא התעסקו רק בלקסיקון סמנטי, סינטטי Patterns,
אלא גם הוסיפו עוד כל מיני אילוצים כמו הקטגוריות של Named entity שמופיעים שם כמו אם זה person או position למשל.
אם מופיע person person name was named organic position.
אז אם אתם יודעים שהראשון הוא שם של בן אדם והנה Identity השני הוא שם של אורגניזם והשלישי הוא שם של position.
אז כמו למשל ג'ורג מרשל UI Secretary of State.
אולי אתם יכולים להסיק שהוא נמצא בתקופה שג'ורג מרשל נמצא בפוזיציה של תפקיד מזכיר המדינה, של ארצות הברית וכולי.
אז בעצם השתמשו בשיטות יותר מתוחכמות.
יש גם שיטות שבעצם מנסות למצוא את ה Patterns.
הם לא מתחילים עם Patterns שמוגדרים ידנית, אלא למשל מנסות לחפש מקרים שבהם נגיד, למשל סימטריה Patterns,
כל מיני תבניות שבהם הפילטר x ו y הרבה פעמים מופיעים גם בצורה כזאת וגם בצורה כזאת, כאילו גם א ב וגם ב.
א. כן. אז למשל אפשר אולי לזהות x as well as y הוא תבנית.
כך זה יוגדר אם אני אראה שהרבה פעמים כשמופיע לי לא יודע מה.
Dogs as well as cats, אז גם מופיע cats as well as dogs יחסית, לא באותו משפט.
כן, אבל שזה גם יהיה משהו נפוץ כן? או Foxes as well as wolves ולהפך וכן הלאה.
ואז, ברגע שאני אזהה את As well as בתור pattern סימטרי, אני אולי יוכל להשתמש בו כדי למצוא למשל סינונים,
כי הרבה פעמים דברים סימטריים מעידים על זה שהמשמעות היא דומה.
כן, שבעצם הם נמצאים בתפקיד דומה אז גם אפשר.
אז במילים אחרות, אם ב 92 זה התבניות שמוגדרות לגמרי ידנית על בסיס מילים ותחביר.
אחרי זה זה השתכלל. להכניס עוד Constant סמנטיים ועוד לשיטות אחרות שמנסות למצוא את התבניות האלה מתוך הגדרות יותר אבסטרקטיות.
כן, כמו כאן כן, ולפעמים גם כאן כמובן צריכים להשתמש בתחביר, כי אחרת די קשה להגדיר מה זה x ו y.
אז למשל, אם נסתכל על as well as, אם היינו פשוט לוקחים את המילה קודם והמילה אחר כך בתור x ו y כן בתור הפילרים של ה כן של הדברים.
המילים שנמצאות ביחס as well as אחד עם השני. אז היינו מקבלים Woods as well as skin.
כן או ריפבליק in and proud.
אוקיי, בעוד שברור שבעצם מה שנמצא פה ביחס דמיון זה לא skin ו Woods, אלא מה?
מה פה אמור להיות במעמד סימטרי ל skin בדיוק walking in the Woods?
כן, אבל בשביל זה אנחנו צריכים תחביר.
תחביר יכול להגיד לנו As well as עובד על skin ועל Walking in The Woods, ואז נוכל לזהות את היחסים בצורה יותר מדויקת.
יפה מושג נוסף שהוא מאוד פשוט, אבל מסתבר שהוא אפקטיבי בצורה מאוד משמעותית.
זה הנושא של distance Supervision מה שנקרא. אוקיי, אז מה?
מה בעצם הרעיון כאן? אז שוב נחזור. נחזור לויקיפדיה.
אוקיי, אז נגיד שאנחנו רוצים להשתמש באמת בוויקיפדיה בוויקי Data.
כן, מה שראינו קודם. הדאטה בייס המאוד מרשים הזה ולמפות כל מיני יחסים שונים בטקסט לתוך הדאטה בייס הזה.
כן, יש בו דאטה על יחסים מאוד אוסף יחסים מאוד עשיר.
ויכול להיות שאנחנו היינו רוצים לחזות אותם בטקסט, אבל הבעיה היא שיש המון המון יחסים בוויקי דאטה.
כן, לא רק שיש המון ישויות, יש גם המון יחסים. אתם ראיתם אולי חלק מהיחסים שיש שם ואלה רק היחסים היחסית נפוצים כמו Space Relative Home Town.
כן, וכן תאריך לידה, שם לידה וכן הלאה וכן הלאה.
אז היינו רוצים להיות מסוגלים לתייג אותם, אבל כמובן שהן label דאטה.
לא נצא מזה אף פעם. כן, יש פשוט הרבה יותר מדי יחסים.
זה לא ילך. אז מה בכל זאת אפשר לעשות? אז הרעיון של דיסטנס סופרוויז'ן זה שבעצם הויקיפדיה עצמה יכולה לשמש לנו כ training data עבור Relation Expression.
אוקיי, באיזה אופן? אז הרעיון הוא סך הכל הרעיון הבא.
כן, שנייה זה פחות זה. אוקיי, אז הרעיון הוא הרעיון הבא.
הרעיון אומר. הרעיון אומר כך.
בוא נגיד שיש לי. אתם יודעים מה יהיה יותר קל לי להדגים את זה פה.
כן. הנה כאן. הממ. אז בוא נגיד שאני רוצה עכשיו למצוא.
איזשהו Relation Extractor כן, איזשהו מודל לומד כן לאמן איזשהו לאמן איזשהו מודל סטטיסטי שיידע לחזות מתי טקסט מצביע על שתי ישויות ככאלה שנשואים זה לזה.
אוקיי, איך אני יכול להשתמש בוויקיפדיה בשביל זה?
אז דבר ראשון אני יכול ללכת ולקחת כל מיני info boxes בוויקיפדיה או כל מיני יחסים מ wiki data זה בעצם שני צדדים של אותו הדבר שבהם יש יחס של Space.
אוקיי, אז אוקיי, ועכשיו יש לי אוסף של זוגות של אנשים כמו למשל בראד פיט וג'ניפר אניסטון, או אני לא יודע מה.
ג'ורג בוש האב ברברה בוש לא יודע, ביל קלינטון והילרי קלינטון וכן הלאה וכן הלאה וכן הלאה.
כל מיני דברים מויקיפדיה, זוגות של ישויות שנמצאות ביחס של Married לפחות באיזשהו שלב.
ועכשיו מה שאני יכול ללכת זה ללכת לדפי וויקיפדיה שלהם לוויקיפדיה Address לפרי טקסט, ולחפש משפטים שבהם גם מצוין הנושא המאמר.
נושא article בראד פיט או מופע אחר שלו?
וגם מצויינת מי שידוע לנו שהיא נשואה או הייתה נשואה זה נהלים כרגע את אלמנט הזמן שמסבך את זה ואז אנחנו רואים שכן.
יש בהחלט משפטים כאלה. למשל Into a Thousand היא Married Actors.
ג'ניפר אניסטון, Whatever divorce in to Fight או Playing a man with a Great games.
רייצ'ל גרין, Please wait, ג'ניפר אניסטון to him to whom it was married at the time.
Plan b entertainment אפילו production company he had found in two years earlier.
ג'ניפר אניסטון אוקיי, אז אחלה. יש לנו כל מיני משפטים שבהם מופיע גם בראד פיט וגם ג'ניפר אניסטון.
ועכשיו, הנה הנחה רדיקלית שלנו. אנחנו הולכים להניח שכל משפט שבהם שבהם מופיעים גם בראד פיט וגם ג'ניפר אניסטון,
מכיוון שאנחנו יודעים שהם היו נשואים אחד לשני, אנחנו הולכים להניח שהמשפט מביע את היחס הזה.
אוקיי. המשפט מביע את היחס הזה. אז בחלק מהמקרים זה יהיה נכון נכון כמו x married Actors y.
זה בהחלט משהו שרומז בזה ש x ו y נשואים או היו נשואים X תהום.
Y was married at the time. גם דוגמה מצוינת.
נכון Instance מצויין. השלישי אולי קצת יותר בעייתי.
X head found. כן, אפילו פרודקשן company x and found the two years earlier with my hands.
זה כבר לא בהכרח רומז. זה יכול להיות בחלק מהמקרים בין אנשים נשואים, אבל כמובן שאין שום הכרח לזה.
ולכן זה בעצם איזשהו רעש. כן, אבל מה אנחנו עכשיו נעשה?
אנחנו בעצם נניח שבגלל שיש לנו, בגלל שוויקיפדיה מספקת לנו כל כך הרבה Instance של X Marie Toy, כן,
שאנחנו יודעים מ Wicked data ולכל אחד מהם כמה וכמה משפטים בתוך ה Entries הרלוונטיים שבהם שתי הישויות מצוינות.
אנחנו הולכים להניח שאנחנו נוכל להתגבר על הרעש הזה. בעצם כן, בעצם אנחנו ניקח ואנחנו נאמן.
אנחנו בעצם נתייחס לזה כאילו זה training data, כאילו דוגמאות נכונות.
זאת אומרת כל מקרים שבהם המשפטים מכילים גם את E1, T1 וגם T2.
נהפוך את זה לניאו training tape ונקווה לטוב.
אוקיי, נקווה שהוא ידע להפריד עכשיו למה שעקרונית הוא יידע להפריד?
בואו נחשוב למה? אולי זה כן הגיוני להניח שהוא לא ילמד.
שכאשר. Expanded production company with why?
זה כנראה לא דוגמה שמציינת שX היה נשוי ל y.
יש מספיק דוגמאות שבהן שניהם לא היו נשואים. X, y y.
כן נכון, אבל. טוב, אבל אני לא אדע שהם תזכורת שרק דוגמאות חיוביות.
נכון, אין לי דוגמאות שליליות, אין לי מקרים של לא היה נשוי ל לפני שהן מאוד חיוביות, אבל יש ככל שאני יודע שההבדל שאתן רואות בדוגמאות דומה יחסית.
אם אין לי כרס אז אני יודע שזה כנראה חיובי, ואם זה פעם אחת הייתי מספיק שתתפנה למשהו עם מישהי אז כנראה לא סיגנל מאוד חזק.
בדיוק. זאת אומרת זה הרעיון. הרעיון שהמקרים שהם נכונים הם יופיעו על פני הרבה זוגות.
זאת אומרת, כל עוד זה לא נכון שהרבה מאוד זוגות נשואים מקימים יחד חברות הפקה יחד עם עוד בן אדם,
אז כנראה הוא הצליח לסנן את הרעש, כי פשוט זה יהיה מעט מאוד דוגמאות כאלה.
יחד עם הרבה דוגמאות אחרות נכונות שהן כן דומות אחת לשנייה.
אוקיי, שהן כן חוזרות על עצמן. אוקיי. כמובן שאם במקרה יצא שאנשים נשואים גם מקימים יחד חברות הפקה, אז מה יקרה?
כנראה נהיה אובססיבי. ואז מה יקרה?
יש עוד שמונה אנשים שמקימים חברות הפקה מסביב.
בדיוק. כן, נכון. אז משפטים שבהם אנשים זה עכשיו יש מקרים שבהם זה עם חברות הפקה.
אני חושב שזה חשש יחסית קטן. נכון, אני מניח שיש הרבה מאוד זוגות נשואים שלא הקימו יחד חברות הפקה, אבל איזה מקרה?
אולי כן יכול להיות מקרה נפוץ? הם גרים ביחד, אולי הם גרים ביחד או אם הכירו.
הם הכירו למרות שהכירו אותה, אומר אנשים מכירים הרבה אנשים, איזה חלק מתוך זה זה כאילו הכירו, יופיע לך גם.
מה שאני מתכוון לומר זה כן כאילו הכירו. הוא יופיע גם עם הרבה יחסים אחרים.
אז אתה צודק, עדיין זה בעיה, אבל בהנחה שתוסיף עוד איזשהו שכלול קטן למודל שאומר שאם משהו מלמד על Instance של יחס איקס אחד,
אז זה מקטין את הסיכוי שהוא מלמד על יחס ב.
כן, אבל אתה צודק, זה גם איזשהו שכלול. אבל מה כן אתה רצית להגיד?
האמת, יש זוג נשוי שיהיה להם ילד.
נולד להם משהו. כן, נכון? אז באמת כל המקרים האלה הם מקרים נכונים המקרים.
מסתבר שהכי מאתגר לסנן אותם הם המקרים שבהם יש קשר סיבתי בין הדברים.
כן. אז למשל, כל האנשים שהתגרשו אחד מהשני ככל הנראה גם נישאו אחד לשני.
באיזה שהוא שלב נכון אז, ולמעשה לפחות אם לקחת את עולמם של שחקני הוליווד, גם הגרירה בכיוון השני היא הרבה פעמים נכונה.
נכון. כלומר, אנחנו נקבל שני יחסים שהם בקולקציה מאוד רצינית אחד עם השני.
נכון, אותם זוגות של ישויות גם מצוינים ככאלה שנישאו וגם כאלה שמצוינים כאלה שהתגרשו לדוגמה, ואז באמת יהיה יותר קשה לסנן.
יהיה לנו שם דרדסים, למרות ששוב זה לא יהיה. זה לא בלתי אפשרי לסמן כן.
כמובן, עדיין יש הקשרים שבהם אנשים נישאו ולא התגרשו וכן ויהיה אפשר להשתמש בסגנון הזה.
אוקיי, אבל מסתבר שיש עוד שיטה מאוד אפקטיבית. כאילו זה נראה כמו הנחה קצת מופרכת.
נכון, אבל בגלל שזה משהו שהוא יחס שמופיע ב info box של אותו entity, ולכן כנראה זה משהו שהוא יחסית מרכזי עבור אותו Entity ומוציא משפט.
בקיצור, יש שם מספיק סיגנל כדי להתגבר על הרעש בהרבה מאוד מקרים.
איך עושים את זה? בגדול עושים את זה עם כל השיטות הסטנדרטיות שהקלו טכנית אלגוריתמית.
זה פשוט משתמש באותם דברים שדיברנו עליהם לאורך הקורס. למשל, אפשר לעשות לזה כן, לבנות מעין סוג של Birds,
לעשות fine tuning ל bird ולנסות לזהות את היחס בין נגיד הנושא והנושא של המשפט או או לשים או לפעמים אתם רואים כמו כאן.
לפעמים מזהים את x ו y מחליפים אותם בתוך Subtext person ואובייקט.
נגיד כאילו פשוט מחליפים אותם באיזשהו סוג של mask, פשוט כדי כדי שכאילו הידע הקיים שלו לא יפריע לה.
כן, כי תשימו לב שיכול להיות שנגיד המודל יודע שבראד פיט וג'ניפר אניסטון נשואים היו נשואים.
אוקיי, כי הוא עבר על הויקיפדיה כמה פעמים. אבל עכשיו במשפט נתון לא כתוב את זה בכלל.
כתוב על יחס אחר כמו שהם הקימו חברת הפקות יחד, או שהם לא יודע מה עשו יחד, הופיעו יחד בפרק של חברים כמו שהיה כתוב שם.
בעצם, יכול להיות שפשוט לציין את השמות שלהם, לגרום לזה הטייה למודל.
אז לפעמים מנסחים את השמות כדי שהוא יתייחס רק כאילו למה המשפט באמת אומר ולא מה המודל?
פשוט למד בחיים בפרי טריינינג. אה?
כן, ואולי זה כן. אז אני אגיד עוד שני דברים אחרונים ונראה לי שנסיים אז.
אוקיי, אז דבר ראשון האבולוציה של Relation אקסטרה אקשן.
בגדול גם כאן הרבה יותר. גם כאן הרבה יותר פשוט לעשות אבולוציה של Precision מאשר של Recall.
ככלל, זה לא קל לדעת מהו כל אוסף.
נגיד, אם יש לכם איזשהו טקסט מאוד ארוך ויש לכם אוסף של כל מיני יחסים, ניסה למונה על ידי, הועסק על ידי טה טה טה טה טה טה טה.
מאוד קשה להשיג בעצם reference של כל היחסים שמובאים על ידי אותו הטקסט.
חלקם מובאים באופן כזה, חלקם באופן כזה, חלקם צריך להקיש אותם מדברים אחרים וכן הלאה, ולכן Precision זה הרבה יותר קל.
מה שלפעמים עושים כדי להתגבר על זה, כדי להתגבר על זה ולא לעשות רק Precision.
נכון, כי תמיד הסכנה בלעשות, אבל יועציה רק ל Precision היא מה.
מה הסכנה בלעשות את זה ליוצר רק לפרסי שם ולא ל recall? חשבתי מראש למחשב שהוא ייתן תמיד תחזית ספציפית.
לא זוכר את סדרת כן אז. כלומר אפשר לחזות נורא מעט יחסים, רק כאלה שאתה נורא בטוח בהם, נכון?
ואז פספסת כמעט הכל, אבל הקלאסי של מאה אחוז.
אולי. אז מה שהרבה פעמים עושים זה מבקשים מהמודלים בעצם לפלוט לא רק את היחסים, אלא גם איכשהו לדרג אותם לפי כמה הכי בטוחים שיתנו ציון דרגת הביטחון.
אוקיי. ואז, כשאתם באים להשוות בין שני מודלים ל information extra action אתם שואלים אוקיי, מה Precision?
בין 100 הראשונים 200 הראשונים כאילו באלה שדרגתי ששדרגו הכי גבוה 300, 400 וכן הלאה.
ואז אתם משווים את המספר. אתם לא אומרים להם תנו 0 או 1.
זה יחס קטן שקיים או לא קיים אלא פשוט תנו ציונים.
למה הסיכוי שזה קיים? ואז אתם קובעים איזשהו Threshold שאתם אומרים?
אוקיי, אני אלך עד אליו. ואני מצפה שה Precision אם המערכת א יותר טובה ממערכת ב.
אני מצפה שה Precision יהיה יותר גבוה על פני ספים שונים.
וגם כמובן אפשר כמו תמיד לעשות אבולוציה אקסטרימית, לראות איך זה עוזר נגיד ל string או לכל דבר אחר.
הנקודה האחרונה שרציתי להעלות זה התחום של Open information extractor, שגם הוא דבר נפוץ.
עוד גישה נפוצה ל information Extensions שבגדול מה שהיא אומרת זה שלא צריך ללכת ולהגדיר אונטולוגיה ידנית וגם אפילו זאת של ויקיפדיה.
היא אולי טובה אם אתם מתעסקים בדומיין של דברים שהם רוצים על ידי ויקיפדיה, אבל אם אתם נגיד עוסקים במאמרים ביו רפואיים, אז אולי ויקיפדיה.
אין שם תמיכה מספיק טובה לכל סוגי היחסים הרלוונטיים. אוקיי, עכשיו במקום ללכת בעצמכם לנסות לחשוב על כל היחסים, מה שכנראה גם תפספסו חלק.
מה שאתם צריכים לעשות זה בעצם להתחיל הפוך. להתחיל מלמטה.
אוקיי, מה הכוונה? אתם צריכים ללכת ולזהות לקחת הרבה הרבה טקסטים.
הדומיין שלכם נגיד מאמרים ביו רפואיים או במקרה שלנו שחקני הוליווד וביוגרפיות שלהם ולזהות שם named entity.
אוקיי, כמו פיט ג'ולי, שוני, אוקלהומה, שילה, נובל וכן הלאה סוקו.
מונט נמיביה וכולי וכולי ובעצם לראות מה הם.
הכנס באנגלית זה עובד טוב כי זו שפה של אובייקט.
נפתח לפני הסוף. זה בעצם ה string שנמצא ביניהם.
אתם בעצם אומרים אני אקח את ה string ביניהם וה 20 ביניהם הוא ישמש כיחס.
הם בעצם אתם הופכים את הטקסט לשם של היחס. אז היחס פה זה born in.
והיחס כאן זה give birth to. אוקיי, בעצם אתם מסתמכים על התחביר יחד עם הצורה שהפרויקט נוסח כדי להגדיר את היחס.
עכשיו מה? מצד אחד נחמד לא צריך להגדיר אונטולוגיה מראש.
אנחנו data driven. אנחנו נאמנים ליחסים שכתובים בדאטה.
מה החיסרון? אפשר אפילו לראות בדוגמה הזאת המון סוגים של יחסים בדיוק, המון סוגים של יחסים, המון סוגים של יחסים והרבה Resonance.
נכון הרבה יתירות כאילו. Gave birth tour זה פשוט אומר שהיא אמא שלך?
כן, כאילו אפשר פשוט לנרמל את כולם ולקרוא לזה בשם של אותו יחס.
כן, אז באמת מה שבדרך כלל עושים זה מנסים איכשהו לאחד אותם ביחד לכל מיני פלסטרים.
וזה באמת הנושא שנקרא סמנטיקה ליבלינג שכבר לא נגיע אליו.
אבל בסדר, לא נורא. מי שמתעניין יכול להסתכל אחרי זה על הרפרנס ששמתי שם במצגת.
אבל בגדול כאן הקושי עובר מהקושי של להגדיר את האונטולוגיה בצורה מדויקת לקושי של לנסות א לאחד יחד דברים שאומרים את אותו דבר.
כן, כמו שמישהי gave birth ממישהו ושהיא אמא ביולוגית של המישהו הזה וכן הלאה וכן הלאה ובעצם
לדעת גם איזה מילים מתוך הפרויקט או בין המילים שנמצאות באמצע הן באמת רלוונטיות.
זאת אומרת, לבחור מה שנקרא את הגרנולה Party, כאילו את הרמת עדינות או גסות הנכונה עבור היחס.
אז אני אתן דוגמא נגיד למשל תיקחו את המשפט הזה גם לאותו בראד פיט פיט first gain recognition.
איזה קקאו ראינו? אני חייב חלק מהמשפט הזה בדגש על Syntax speed first gain recognition, cowboy hike or in the road movie terminal לואיס.
אוקיי, עכשיו אפשר בהחלט מהמשפט הזה להגיד זה משפט שמבטא את היחס X.
First gain recognition. זהו זה Cowboy hike in the road movie while.
וזה יחס סמנטי. לגיטימי. מה הבעיה איתו?
אף אחד? זה נכון?
אבל למה? תודה. כן, כנראה זאת אומרת, אלא אם עוד אנשים לראשונה הוכרו, קיבלו הכרה דרך תפקיד כבקר.
שייקר בראון מובי. אולי זה קרה כנראה לא המון פעמים. אז השאלה היא בעצם איך?
אולי צריך לפצל את זה לכמה יחסים נכון? מה הרמה הנכונה?
האם להגיד שפיט gain recognition from the above ey?
אולי זה הצורה הנכונה? אולי להגיד כן להגיד שפיט gain recognition ואז להגיד שזה יחס טרנדי בין בן אדם
שקיבל את התפקיד פיט הסרט תלמיד לואיז והתפקיד שלו קאובוי Hitachi Car וכן הלאה.
איך בדיוק מנתחים את זה? זה הופכת להיות בעצם הכובד.
המשימה עובר לשם. הזיהוי הוא כבר פשוט כי הוא ישירות מתוך המשפט והקושי עובר בעצם לבניית האונטולוגיה על בסיס הדאטה.
אוקיי, אז שיעור הבא שיעור חזרה נעלה מבחנים, תשאלו שאלות במייל ונתראה.
תודה רבה. טוב.
לא. ממש צריך להתעסק בדברים אחרים של אוטומציה כנראה קופץ מדי.
חזק מדי. למה? למה למה?
לא להתייחס אליו כאל טיפוס או לא?
מה שאני מתכוון לומר זה שאם אתה עכשיו רוצה להגדיר מה אתה רוצה שהוא יתייחס אליו כרגע, אבל בוא נגיד שאתה רוצה לרפא את היחסים האקולוגיה.
אז כמו שאמרנו קודם, אתה רוצה סטנדרטיזציה כי אתה עושה Structural כדי שתוכל לעשות את מה שהם רוצים, ובנוסף באמת אתה מחלק אותו לכל חלקים עוד קטנים.
מה זה משפט בא במשפט? עכשיו אתה לא מתכוון לומר את מה שאת רוצה בעצם?
לקחת את הטקסט ולהפוך אותו למילים של דייט? אז אתה צריך להחליט ללמד יחסים את הבחור שאתה הולך לייצג?
עכשיו יש הרבה דרכים לייצא את כל המידע שלו, נכון?
אתה יכול להגיד שזה פשוט חוויה מאוד ספציפית שהתחילה רק שורה אחת בשווקים שהיא מתייחסת אליה.
התשובה היא. כנראה אין מצב שלא חשבתי לעצמי שלאחר מכן כן.
אז. זה מה שאתה צריך?
ביי ביי. הייתה לך מיזוג? אתה רוצה להחליט מראש אם אתה רוצה להירשם רק כשאתה רוצה לייצר הכנסה?
אתה רוצה אתר? אני לוקח את הזמן ואתה אומר על זה.
יש לי את הניסיון של היחסים הבאים נישואים בין x ו y גירושין וזה.
במקום כל מה שאמרת בעולם שקורה כל אחד מאיתנו.
נולד ב 1. יש מספיק זוגות וזה מספיק.
אף אחד לא מבין איך הגיע ליעד X שהוא מחפש, איך הוא בודק מה ואיך, ואז הוא משיב.
למשל זה אחד אצלך? כן, אתה יודע בדיוק איך להרגיש.
צריכים לעשות לו המון דברים. אתה יכול לבדוק מהם הזוגות הנפוצים.
בדרך כלל שבדרך כלל. הם מציגים את זה.
אתה יכול לחתוך טבלאות? כן, זה ממש כיף.
לא יודע כמה שינויים. בגלל שהוא מאוד. אוהב את עצמו.
יש. לך כל מה?
שצריך? לדעת?
כששואלים. אותי.
לשם. מה זה?
טוב אני צריכה סליחה.
סליחה סליחה בבקשה סליחה.
אני מבינה שאנחנו מתחילים אז העשרה לשלום המסכן חצי שעה לא לשבת בשורה האחרונה והקשה.
שורה אחת כן, שורה אחת לא בכוונה כן.
מי כתב בכוונה? ריטה? בבקשה בבקשה לבדוק שאתם לא שומעים את עצמנו.
סליחה, בבקשה לבדוק שאתם מופיעים אצלנו ומגיע לכם תוספת זמן כשמופיע לכם תוספת זמן.
כן. מה הם אומרים?
זה שונה? דבר ראשון. אני מדבר איתך.
לא משנה מה אתה עושה אתה צריך לשאול את.
עצמך.